Hello everybody!
Welcome back to Sandland!
I think it's been like, what, two weeks since we played part two?
This is the worst thing I can do in my channel.
Uh, play- okay, here's a pro tip for you guys.
Um, playing- doing a part three of a series two weeks later of a long- of a sort of RPG game is not the smartest thing you should do.
But, I don't care, cause I actually was enjoying Sandland, so...
But I don't care!
Because Sandland has been very enjoyable!
And like, even though it's been through- two weeks since we played part two, and a lot of you might have already forgotten what the fuck happened.
It's okay, we're starting a new story because apparently, um...
In part two, we finished the original story of Sandland.
And we were just about to start a new story where we're not in the sand anymore.
Uh, so there's that.
Also cause like, Bandai has been treating me really well.
Like the, uh, Bandai America and I guess like JP as well.
Um, they've been treating me really well.
And like, you know what, like, I honestly have been enjoying Sandland.
And I was like, uh, I'm gonna keep going.
I'm gonna keep going, keep advertising Sandland for doing good.
For those who forgot about it.
Uh, cause I enjoy the game.
And I enjoy Bandai.
Um, but yes!
Let's go!
Alright, Sandland.
Guys, like I said, you actually don't have to know about what happened last time.
Because we're starting a whole new fucking story.
Uh, thank you for the- uh, gift the chip, Deadpool!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Oh, why is my controller not working?
No!
Did it register my fucking mouse?
Okay, I hope I don't get, uh, marked for demonetization for saying the F word.
Alright guys, I need to reboot the game.
Cause I have to- I had to boot it up while I was on a controller.
Give me a sec.
Alright, we're starting a new season.
A new season of sand.
Where it's green now.
Uh...
Also, like, uh, just want you guys to know.
Next week will be, quote unquote, wet rest week.
Other than, like, I think I have that Twitch Rivals thing.
Wait, it's actually not registering.
Excuse you.
Excuse me?
Hello?
Okay, maybe if I click continue, it'll register.
Say!
Okay, maybe if I, like, press escape.
And go to- Oh!
Alright!
Let's go!
Control setup.
There we go.
Yes, control type.
Yes!
Control type!
Oh!
Alright.
My- I'm sorry.
Okay, I have an idea.
I have an idea on how to fix this.
Okay.
Uh, controller settings.
Yes!
Okay.
Does that mean it's gonna...
configure it now?
Does that...
It says...
controller's activated.
How did I- How did I do this?
How did I-
Was I playing a controller last time?
Oh, I did it!
I did it!
I had to replug it!
Oh my gosh.
I knew it.
When all else fails, just...
plug in it- turn it on and off again.
Alright.
Oh, hey, there was a monkey.
Guys, I don't remember how to play this game.
Uh, what was the object- Oh, I have to talk- Oh, I have to talk to the- talk to people!
Yes, there we go.
Oh my gosh, is Tenjin here?
Okay, I need to moderate Tenjin.
Hey, Tenjin.
Oh, shit!
Tenjin's a member!
Oh my god!
Alright.
Nice.
You're just a standard moderator.
You don't have that much power on my channel.
Oh my- Tenjin!
You fake-ass fan!
You're a fake-ass fan!
You said you were always a member!
What the fuck happened?
You're a tomato!
That's like the first membership!
If you were always a member, you would have been an egg right now.
Thank you for joining the tomato farm, Tenjin.
I hope you had a great debut.
I was sleeping, so I couldn't retweet it in time.
I was- I was tired.
Is that what he thinks?
I'm sorry.
Let's bring them more supplies later and see if they can fix my console.
Sounds like a plan.
Oh my god.
Congratulations on your debut, Tenjin.
You should- You know what?
But you didn't gorilla stream it.
You said the moment everything's ready, you would make a waiting room and turn your stream on.
You really lied to me.
Master drop, thank you for the fish!
I'm so happy!
Thank you, thank you!
Get the chips!
Us too?
What do you mean?
We've lost contact with the unit tasked to guard the battleship.
And when we dispatched another nearby unit to investigate, they were in AWOL 2.
Fake and real friends.
Real G.
So now you want the old man to look into it for you?
The Elzebub.
I didn't realize you were there.
Wait, someone stole our ships?
It's not a ship.
No!
You never know where I might show up.
The taxpayer's money!
The battleship belonged to Zeyu.
Check out Tenjin.
He just recently debuted, guys.
He has a new skin suit now.
Something about his chin?
I saw...
Tenjin, why was everybody talking about your chin?
I didn't watch your debut yet.
I'm confused.
Would you like to explain if you're still here?
Tenjin, what's going on?
Oh, Tenjin.
Why are people calling you Tenjin?
Well, you heard the brief.
Are you two coming along?
Sure.
Sounds fun.
Thanks.
I just hope we don't run into anything too crazy.
Having Mountain of the Chin.
What is it?
Going up?
But like... that game.
But on Tenjin's chin.
Tenjin's chin.
Yeah.
Zeyu's battleship crash landed somewhere around the big dam.
Is that where the peach is?
Yes.
How do I...
The Royal Army.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
I need to grab the tank.
Because it's fast.
Wait, no.
I need to get a motorcycle because it's faster.
The others can walk.
In fact, we don't know.
Maybe their transmitter just malfunctioned.
Well, I certainly hope so.
All right.
Off I go.
It's alright.
I don't really care about the others.
They can just walk.
Wait, do I fast travel?
Where is it?
Oh, no.
It's too far.
The fast travel is not...
Wait, unless...
Is this...
No.
I don't have the fast travel for this.
Guys, I found out.
So apparently...
By the way, guys.
Apparently...
What the fuck?
There's a crocodile now in this game?
Wow!
Okay.
I was so busy looking at the crocodile.
It almost fell off.
Okay.
What was I going to say?
Oh, yeah.
Apparently, if I had done the side quest, I could have decorated my base and everything and also put stickers and changed the colors of my tanks.
So like...
Oops.
All right.
Well, oopsie.
Apparently, you know, I didn't...
I had a bad day.
I didn't unlock any of the actual fun parts of this...
Like the actual fun parts of customization of this game just because I've been ignoring all these side quests.
Oopsie.
So you know that 50 chairs I got?
The 50 chairs I got from the...
From pre-ordering?
Yeah.
I still own 50 chairs.
I'm sorry.
Oh, good.
Also...
Oh.
She got the visor fake thing.
You didn't...
Yeah, I was not sure why I wanted to go tochaft.
Oh, my gosh.
These guys are like the complete twits.
Shouldn't be.
Oh, I thought my cards were set.
With the flower pot.
Well...
That is...
That is like...
Yeah...
Wow.
We're almost there.
Yeah, we're almost here.
No, it's not my fault.
You just didn't yell hard enough at me.
If you yell hard enough at me, then I couldn't choose to not see because I'll be like, Whoa!
There's way too many people saying that.
So how can I choose to ignore it if it's harder to ignore?
You get me?
You understand?
Oh yeah, you're a social super chat.
There are only a few, sure.
But with large groups, you risk getting surrounded.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do I go?
Is this where we go to Greenland?
Oh my god, this guy's dead.
Oh no, he's dead!
I wish you could have ran him over.
Baddai, you're hearing this?
That would have been so- Baddai, I actually don't hear this.
Baddai, I- Please don't take my advice.
You okay?
What the heck just happened?
Some group I've never seen before suddenly attacked me.
Zeon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello chat, is I a dragoon who has plaz this game?
Dokis Town has no features because she skipped every side quest.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not on purpose!
It was not willingly skipped, okay?
They just didn't put it in my face hard enough.
More like passed out.
Who could defeat elite royal army soldiers in an instant?
Yeah, who could do that?
Wait, can I still unlock it?
Or did I like leave my home already?
Guys, it doesn't mean- Guys!
It doesn't mean that I can't unlock it!
Alright, what- Okay guys, you know what?
Fuck you guys.
Okay, I'm gonna do this out of spite now.
We're not going to Greenland anymore!
We could have been in Greenland already, but we're not going to Greenland anymore!
We're gonna- We're gonna unlock features!
Where- Where is our home?
We demand green.
Guys, I'm having trouble finding Greenland, like our home.
Oh, it's here.
That should be it.
Why can't I fucking fast travel?
Fast travel to this.
Oh, I have to like zoom in, I guess.
It has to be this.
Yeah.
No?
Wait, this is not my home.
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm trying to remember where we used to live.
This is- No, this is the nest.
Guys, where did we live?
That's the ruins.
That's the- Espino?
Guys, I don't even know where we lived.
Guys.
That's deemed space.
Talbot?
Nests?
Water Supply?
Where's my house?
Oh, Espino, there you are!
Are you gonna pick up Fallout 4 again?
Young Thank you for Super Chat!
thank- thank you!
I'm going to see after, uh after Sandland.
We'll see.
Thank you for Super Chat, Young.
Thank- thank you.
S Ankermit, thank you much.
Why did you get the ships?
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, what was the first side quest, guys?
Come on.
There's not even any side quests!
Here.
There's nobody offering side quests.
Golden help, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Stop complaining, I swear to God.
We are turning this car around and doing the side quest chat.
We don't... then why are you complaining?
You guys don't even know which one were the side quests!
Alright, go to the quest menu.
You guys didn't even know.
Oh, whoa!
Okay, guys.
This is awkward because they still have not yet fixed this.
That's the guy that plotted it.
How do I... how do I improve my home that I'm gonna leave anyway?
Guys!
Guys that plotted this!
You said... you said there were side quests I should be doing.
Where is it?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Got the email that I received a gift of membership.
Thanks.
Oh, hi Doki.
This guy's only here for the chat.
The dragoons were the main show for Gavilan.
Doki was the bonus.
Suspicious...
Yeah, but which one is the one that would unlock stuff?
Guys, you can't just be like, go look at the yellows.
Not every yellow is a fucking side quest I should be doing.
And this... and this five.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Have you forgotten?
Dragoons argue with each other as much as we complain.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys!
Like, not every side quest here indicates the one that will give me the...
That will give me free shit.
Okay.
Uh...
Cosmogdon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Improve your home with putting green.
Yeah, I guess it could be the suspicious cave?
Okay, I'm gonna go check out the suspicious cave.
That has to be it.
I swear to god.
If this doesn't give me what I want...
I swear to god, chat.
Ooh.
You don't wanna make Doki angry.
I'm practicing.
Let me put my white shirt on.
Okay.
Alright.
Um...
Let's see.
I'm gonna head this way.
Uh...
This is one of them.
Alright.
Let's hope this is one of them.
I really want to see Doki.
We should think about stopping by that campsite they're using ourselves.
It's a community.
Burrito, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Think about it.
Life is just a series of side quests.
Let us live our life, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's open the wall trap.
Alright, let's see.
$10 for chat, we deserve it.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Who the fuck are you?
Zeph?
Who are you?
Were you just created for just this quest?
Thank you for the 10 gifted shit.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, I should learn to read your name.
Sorry, I can't read very well.
Especially like...
I can't read English very well.
So like any other language is also pretty bad for me.
So let me actually learn to read your name.
Because you've been supporting me a lot.
Alright.
Parupo.
I hope I pronounced it right.
Parupo, thank you for the...
Thank you for the 10 gifted shit.
Thank you, thank you.
That's me!
Yep!
Wait, I can actually do his voice.
I'm the...
The Crown Prince of Beelzebub!
Am I close?
No.
Guys, you're supposed to be my fucking echo chamber.
So what if you're the Fiend Prince?
I'm a hunter.
What's the point of streaming if I have not created an echo chamber to say I'm right on everything?
And to get you dragged to the next target I plan on bagging.
A demon child's nothing in comparison.
You're hunting Gedji Dragons?
What's Gedji Dragons?
Are those the ones I've been running over?
Best drop that dud of a plan now.
Even I'm no match for that beast.
Ha!
Don't put you and me in the same basket.
I've compiled the Gedji Dragon Strategy Guide to bring it down.
Hm.
Sounds interesting.
Let me take a look at it.
Ooh!
That's the way to kill the Gedji Dragon.
If one really exists, I'm also interested.
Oh, that's the thing that chased me in the back?
Let's make them extinct!
Let's go!
Environment dis- what was it?
Environment terrorism?
You'll have to fetch it yourself.
Ecological terrorism?
Is that what it's called?
Like, making a fucking species extinct?
Bring it to me and I'll let you read it.
Heck, I'll even pay you.
I guess.
In game.
In game, guys.
Wait, what is that?
What's ecoterrorism, then?
Is that really bad?
I mean, I saw- Wait, actually, they're all really bad.
Oh, shit!
Sorry!
I didn't know what it actually meant.
Wait, let me look it up.
Oh my god.
Wait, what did I just say yay to?
Eco- Okay...
I thought that meant getting rid of- Oh, that's when you support the environment and you do bad things.
Oh!
Sorry, I'm here to do the opposite of that.
But like...
But to make things extinct.
Okay.
Yeah, we're not doing that.
It's the opposite of that.
Okay.
I learned something new today, guys.
Guys, thank you for educating me.
Alright.
Guys.
Thank you for educating me, guys.
I got educated.
So, yay!
See?
This is a learning stream.
Guys, we're all learning together about what words mean.
Chat.
We're all learning.
Alright.
I hope Bandai is not watching me right now.
I'm sorry.
I know Bandai is not watching because like...
They are legally obligated to be like, Hi Doki if they're in my chat.
Yeah, Bandai!
Bandai!
Alright.
Let's see.
Where did I take this quote?
Oh, wait.
No, I...
Wait, I was supposed to still be there.
The cave is here.
Alright.
How do I get into this suspicious cave?
Oh, there it is.
It has to be it.
Oh, nope.
Okay, get off this.
I need to change it to this.
Yeah, get off your fucking truck, old man.
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Platt guy!
Oh, shit!
Okay, wait.
Zia, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Since Doki wants to be told exactly.
That's right.
That's me.
Desert soldier recruits Moss who will then give you the mysterious voice side quest in town.
Who the fuck is a desert soldier?
Oh, is this it?
Wait.
Oh, I'm not sure.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, there it is!
Okay, well, there's still gonna be a dragon problem.
Here, guys.
Oh, well.
Oh, my God.
We don't care about that.
Sorry.
Sorry, man.
Your side quest was not as important.
This way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Doki wants to be the captain planet villain.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You think about it.
The kids on Captain Planet, they're the bad guys.
They do extreme things.
What to do?
I'm in a bind.
Yes.
Oh.
Hello?
I hear mumbling.
Desert soldier!
Me!
Yes!
I'm busted!
This must be my end.
Yes!
What?
Why?
Oh, Shariko, thank you for the super chat.
No.
No, I am not.
I'm not.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What are you going on about?
Wait.
You're not a wannabe junker.
Of course not.
Yeah.
I'm the fiend prince.
I'm the fiend prince Beelzebub.
Beelzebub.
You fiend!
Shaking in your boots, are you?
You're scary, yes.
Also, were you saying Captain Planet?
I'll take up the many one right now.
Even a fiend.
You can tell people who don't know what you're talking... like the age differences between the two.
I mean the people in my chat.
Please, save me, yes?
With the people who don't know who the fuck Captain Planet is and the people who do.
So like...
It like sort of dates you.
The only reason I know who Captain Planet is, is because of Rick and Morty.
So like that sort of like tells like...
How about we hear what he has to say?
I was not there to watch Captain Planet.
He's no dookie.
Hmm.
I'm not a dookie.
Oh no, she's profiling us.
Okay guys, when did Captain Planet release?
Captain Planet... um... release year... 1990!
Oh my god!
I'm pretty sure they never made a sequel.
I've never heard anything...
Oh wait, the new adventures of Captain Planet.
When was this?
Oh no, that was also pretty old.
Dookie, stop!
Oh shit!
1990?
Oh, I knew it was old, but I didn't realize it was that old.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
It's okay guys.
Don't...
That's why I'm streaming.
Okay.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Chat.
Y'all looking good today.
How have you been?
Playing any good games?
Doing anything fun this summer?
Stay cool, Chat.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Alright, here.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Okay, Grandma.
Dookie.
Dookie, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
The Junkers?
What did you do?
Grinkle, thank you for the five good dishes!
Thank you!
Yeah, what did you do?
Oh my god, he's a good guy!
I plowed on in with my tank and drove them away, yes?
Oh, okay, I thought he meant he ran them over with his tank and I was like, maybe he's not that good of a guy!
I was like, whoa!
I don't know if a good guy would run people over with their cat tank.
Now I'm hiding away in here, yes?
But it won't be long before they find this old shack.
And when they do, I just know I'll be...
What will you be?
I shudder to even think of it.
Anything forbidden, huh?
Thank you for the super chat, thank you!
If I like being old, I have old man power!
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
You get to have your own credit card and your own mortgage!
You know, it's good to be old because that means you can have credit cards.
And by having credit cards, you can super chat to your Oshii.
Yeah?
True.
Wink wink.
Aphelion, thank you for the 10 gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
It's my fault!
It's never my fault!
Alright, fine.
I'm bold to assume I have good credit.
Ooh, the woes of being... What the fuck?
Where did these guys come from?
Oh, okay, these are the guys that...
These... Okay, guys, I'm gonna do something not very...
Alright, you pissed me off, guys.
I just wanted to color my tank.
There we go.
This might be a little extreme.
I love the Steve truck!
Now it's my turn to run them over.
True Boomers unite!
Thanks for the smile!
Thank you for the Akasuba!
Thank you, thank you!
Gary, thank you for the super chat!
Oh, thank you so much!
Yes!
That means I can...
Yes, you're free now!
A bit of an overkill bringing in the tank, but that's okay.
I can do now.
What do you mean?
Do whatever you want.
Yeah, you're free now.
Sure.
But now that I've been discharged from the Royal Army...
I don't have anywhere to go.
Come live in my town!
For real?
If he's got nowhere else to go...
I am a just prince.
How about inviting him to Spino?
Who's also the devil.
Right!
You can just go to Spino!
Gamble!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Wink, wink!
It's a town looking for new residents!
Marvelous!
Yeah!
You're literally our first resident!
After eight hours!
We finally recruited another civilian!
Well, there's so few inhabitants.
It's almost a ghost town.
Oh, but it's not my fault though, I think.
I bet they'd be happy to have you.
Yeah, come live in my empty ass town so I can tax you later.
In that case, I might indeed be of use to them, yes.
I'll give it a shot, yes!
Oh my god, thank you!
Can I now color my tank?
Is my tank, like, colorable now?
Okay.
Let's check.
Oh my god, this is what it's like to have, like, a new resident?
Now pay my taxes.
Alright.
And then he's supposed to give me a quest too.
Where is he?
Where do you live?
Where the fuck do you live?
Okay, what did the- What did the dragoon who plotted this say?
I- After- After I saved that man's life.
Because now he owes me.
In the back?
Do I just, like, talk to him?
Okay, let's see...
He got killed already?!
I, like, just recruited him!
Yeah, of course.
If you live in my town, you would get, uh...
Good taxes.
Not the fake taxes in wherever you live now.
Hehehehe.
Uhhh...
Where is he?
Why is he hiding from me?
I don't understand.
Why would you hide from me?
Hehehehe.
Why?
Where are you?
I need the taxes.
Okay.
Hehehehe.
The other side?
Where the fuck is he?
Wait, is he actually hiding from- Is he- There you are.
Hello.
Oh shit, no.
Yes!
Oh, wait, what?
Is that it?
Hiding from the tax man.
Hehehehe.
Wait.
Oh my god!
Guy who plotted this!
What quest do I have to do next?
Cool quest.
Yeah, cool quest, bro.
Born to be silly.
Obliged to- Obligated to taxivate.
Alright.
Guess I have to...
Go out?
Oh, go outside and reload.
Okay.
Sorry.
My man has to be- My man has to reload his brain real quick.
No.
It still isn't offering it to me.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
You're still not gonna offer me the quest?
Are you serious?
I'm coming over.
The tax man is coming.
Are you ready to pay the tax toll?
I'm gonna worry the money.
Okay.
Yes!
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What is wrong with you?
You're living in my town for free.
Give me my quest!
Every new civilian that moves into this quest has to- Has to pay the tax.
Or give me a quest.
The tax man is scary.
Listen, my man needs to be in the mood for questing.
Okay.
Oh, I need to finish the cave?
Are you fucking kidding me?
No!
I have to make an entire species extinct?
Ah, fine.
I guess if I am going to kill off an entire race...
I guess I...
I'm the best person for the job.
Alright.
Where is my motorcycle?
It's a very short quest.
I mean, I know because I'm very good at it.
Alright, here we go.
I'm very good at killing things in game.
Alright.
It is right here.
This is it.
Yeah!
We're coming over.
The things I do so I can put stickers on my car.
Make sure to check your computer.
You'll never know when something you've picked up might come to you.
Here you go.
Is that the strategy guide?
Wait, what the fuck?
Where is he?
Looks like it.
Oh my god, this is just free shit.
Is that it?
Give the guide to...
Wait, there's no dragon here.
I've been lied to!
It's literally just free items.
Alright.
Here we go.
Is that it?
Is that everything?
I think that's everything.
Alright, let's go back up.
Alright, I got you the book.
Where are you?
Wait, where's the guy?
Where is he?
Oh, he's over here.
Alright.
I got you your shit.
My dude.
Oh ho ho!
You really brought it.
Thanks!
Here's your reward.
Still, talk about tough luck.
After so many natural disasters.
There might be other blocked caves like this one.
True.
We'll keep an eye out for them.
Never mind that.
You'll let me read that guide, right?
Yeah.
I, Zeth, the giant beast hunter wrote it.
Read it with care.
Oh!
He gave me an instruction guide on how to kill other beasts.
What do we have here?
What sloppy handwriting.
A good match for Kyuki.
Oy!
What's this?
Old man, this looks like it was written by a toddler.
I wrote it on the road, so you might have to squint a little.
Why the fuck just rewrite it?
But it can't be that bad.
You write and drive?
Guys, don't write and drive.
Oh my god, Zeth!
Like right here, it says...
Why are you teaching these kids to write and drive?
Dragging a...
Oof.
See?
Damn.
Guess I have to rewrite it.
How unlucky can you get?
Next time, sit down one day.
Yeah.
This is why, guys.
Don't write and drive, everybody.
I know that.
I'll rewrite it carefully once I find a base for my hunt.
A base?
You're looking for a place to stay?
Wait, live in my house!
You should go to Spino then.
Yeah!
Spino?
Oh my god, finally another resident attacks.
I see.
Which means there aren't a whole lot of inhabitants yet.
Oh my god, guys.
Our town is gonna be so rich.
And by so rich, the one person that runs this town is gonna be so rich.
Alright, I'll move into that.
And once I'm done with the book, Gadgetragon will be on the menu.
Guess you'll be going hungry.
Another civilian!
I think you're unfortunately right.
Double the...
People, double the taxes.
That's...
Economics, baby.
Alright.
Now!
Now I should have some quests now, right?
Oh wait, I gotta get rid of all these check marks I made.
Alright, here you go.
A true gamer grinding for hours just for cosmetics.
Nice turn.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Infinite money glitch!
Not for the citizens living here, of course.
But for me!
I'm gonna...
Oh, is that it?
Do I now have enough civilians for a quest?
Oh my god.
Hello, sir.
I got us...
I got us some civilians, Mayor.
Enough what?
Yeah.
What's going on, Grandpa?
I'm gonna go get some more supplies.
Which is why I thought this would be a great opportunity.
For what?
To build new facilities for the town.
Oh my god!
That sounds great.
Where's the problem then?
We can finally have new homes!
We don't have enough materials to build new bridges or buildings.
Oh.
Oh yeah, we're poor.
We can make do salvaging old materials here and there.
I forgot about that.
But scraps are scraps.
I'd like to use something more...
I don't know much about construction.
It sounds like a lot of work.
Yeah, it does.
Work is hard.
Well, it would go faster if I could lay hands on some raptor steel.
God fucking dammit.
Not the raptor steel.
Raptor steel?
What's that?
It's a kind of metal that's been alloyed with raptor scales.
It's stronger and more malleable than normal steel.
Bolts, nuts...
You can even make pipes with it.
It can be used for almost anything.
It's just...
It can be used to upgrade vehicles too.
I know that.
I've been using it for vehicles.
Upgrade vehicles?
For real?
Beelzebub, we've been doing this for like the last two parts.
Beelzebub.
Now you've got his interest.
I'll help you get some if it means we can upgrade our stuff.
I love the 3D models for this game.
It's so good.
I think...
It doesn't look like a 3D model too.
Wonderful.
Your help would be most appreciated.
However, you can't just find raptors.
Thank you.
You're a pilot.
Only a skilled material processor would be capable of crafting some.
Then we just need to bring someone like that to Spino.
A skilled material processor?
Oh, that's right.
Back in the day, I used to know a skilled craftsman called Norrs.
Nowadays, he's running a workshop in Talbo, I think.
Could you go see him for me?
Oh, yeah.
Of course.
Talbo?
Okay.
Guys, I just realized I put so much effort...
Like, I'm putting so much effort in this town.
But we're going to be leaving this town the moment I get the stickers.
And everything I've done to this town will be for nothing.
Because I won't be able to use it.
I won't even be able to use this stupid village.
Don't think about it.
Yeah?
For the stickers, Doki.
Just think about the sticker.
Guys, I just...
I just want to paint.
I just want to paint the tank.
And use my 50 chairs.
That's all I want.
Why?
Where does this guy fucking live?
Where does he live?
Get the flowers...
Is it this one?
It has to be this one, right?
Icon list...
Okay, I need to get rid of some stuff on my icon list.
I feel like...
You are...
Okay, I need to know where I am.
Uh...
What is this?
Where's self?
Self?
Okay, north is up.
South is...
Down.
Right?
Crying...
Where is it?
Grotto...
Taboo...
Is this?
Where is it?
You guys lied to me.
Where the fuck is it?
Where's Taboo?
Guys, where is Taboo?
Okay...
This is the NEPS base.
This is the NEPS checkpoint.
Oh, there's Taboo!
Oh, there it is.
Found Taboo.
I found Taboo.
Oh my god.
Get in here.
I'm gonna abduct you to my town.
Stan...
Wait, his name is Stan?
We are in an area where people's names are fucking Bezelbub and your name is Stan?
Uh...
Alright.
And what does a demon like you want with me?
Huh?
We need you for parts.
Are you looking for a material processor called Norse?
Stan the man.
Don't bully the man, Cass-Stan dude.
Yeah, Cass?
Is it because your name is also Stan?
Oh shit, I'm sorry Stan!
Bro!
Oh my god, now he's sad guys!
You made him... you made Stan sad!
Yeah, how are we supposed to get that stuff?
What do you mean I'm the rude one?
Or live in my town Stan?
Yeah, live in my town!
Why would you want to live here?
Yeah, but we want it to be convenient.
I like how we don't even... we skip the explanation.
What?
But our town doesn't have a Stan!
We need to fill the quota of names!
I can't just leave my little sister here on her own.
Well she can live with us!
Is her name also Stan?
Damn it...
Why can't her little sister live with us?
Oh, her name is Vess.
I heard everything!
Don't worry little demon, I'll come to Spino!
Stan it!
Yeah!
Vess!
Don't talk nonsense!
It's not nonsense!
I've been thinking for a while.
You didn't even know Spino existed!
That I want to leave the nest and open a workshop of my own!
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say, she's like...
The moment I heard Spino, like five minutes ago, I knew that was the town for me.
No!
I won't allow it!
Even with Pop's friend there, you can't go to a new town alone!
It's always the same!
We got the woman!
It's so Stan!
Let me live my own life!
Yeah!
I said no!
Period!
If you won't listen, then I'll go to Spino myself!
What the f- Okay, that's like, fucked up bro.
This is like her dream.
And then you're like, you know what, fuck you, I'm gonna take your dream!
I bet they'd rather have someone skilled anyway.
Woah!
What'd you say?
Don't think I didn't hear that!
Wow Stan, rude!
Wait, you're right, we need women in this town!
We recruit two male civilians!
Guys, we need to balance the population out in our town!
Of course I am!
That's it!
Let's face off to see who'll go to Spino!
Oh shit, fight, fight, fight!
Face off?
We'll both make Raptors steal and see whose is better!
This little demon here will be the judge!
Winner goes to Spino!
Sounds fun!
Oh my god, I get free Raptor steal guys!
I love free stuff!
That okay with you little demon?
Fine by me!
Oh no, this is just like my Japanese fan comment!
Right after you lend us a pure Raptor steal, that is.
Oh now you guys don't want Stan!
Just cause we have Vest now!
What happened guys?
You guys were cheering on Stan!
But now you don't want him anymore?
What the fuck happened?
Not loyal, that's what happened!
We just ran out!
Ah, sure!
Alright, we need some Pur-Purupdar scales.
Do I have Purupdar scales?
You need Purupdar scales to make Raptors!
There's a Raptor cave north- Wait, that ran out?
How did I fucking ran out?
Okay, where the fuck is the cave?
This one, right?
Paterno...
Um...
Alright, we'll just...
There has to be some Raptors nearby!
You have to give- yeah, but like...
But like, how- when did I- I ran out of fucking scales!
Can I just buy them?
Paterno!
Uh...
You're not useful at all.
Alright.
North or something.
This is north?
Oh, there it is!
Alright.
Oh, I should get rid of this then.
Alright, there you go.
Oh, I should get a tank.
Cause we're gonna be running over some Raptors.
Alright.
He just told me- yes, but he used...
marginal directions.
Guys, I don't think you remo- You guys forgot I'm stupid.
Alright, nice.
We're gonna kill the whole family.
Because...
This is important.
Oh, hey!
Nice!
Three for one special!
Oh, we've ended!
There was someone there to rescue?
Nice.
Wait, that's just a Raptor scale.
Wait, it's just a regular Raptor scale.
Any special Raptor scale?
Uh, Magister.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Since we're all boomers here, can you finish this sentence?
And that's the bottom line because...
Is that a reference to something?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Behind me?
Back when Taobao was thriving, this town was filled to the brim with craftsmen.
No way.
Alright, guys.
Leave me alone.
I don't get that reference.
Guys, don't pretend you don't understand that reference, guys.
Don't...
Guys, don't pretend, guys.
Oh, there it is.
There's the Raptor cave.
What do you mean?
We're literally here.
Oh.
Your Raptors are rare.
I doubt they'll be that easy to find.
What is a P-Raptor?
I thought all Raptors are the same.
Oh my god, look.
There's eggs.
You make me feel old.
That's why you watch me.
To feel young again.
Guys.
I'm here to make you guys feel young again.
What?
Yeah, P-Raptor the Raptor.
Well.
No!
Oh, my tank.
Yes.
No!
My tank can't fucking go upstairs.
This is fucked up.
This is so fucked up.
Here?
Where is it?
Where is the P-Raptor?
Oh, there he is!
Oh my god.
They're white.
Okay.
Guys.
You know they said they're very rare.
So let's make them rar- So let's make them rarer.
Hahaha.
Goodbye.
Give me a sec.
Doki, no!
Hahaha.
I need these materials.
Supply and demand, baby.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
Rare to endanger.
Yay!
Make the mix.
Do it for the- Guys, it's for the stickers!
Guys.
Doki, yes!
It's for the stickers!
We worked so hard for those stickers, chat.
Alright, let's see.
Uh, where is...
There you go.
Albo.
If you ever think you might be lost, you should check the map.
That's on them for not- For not adapting to the tanks.
Getting lost and having a backtrack would be a pain.
Oh, oh!
I either- guys!
I think like, I give the raptor steel to either Stan or Vess.
To choose whoever we want, guys.
Alright, who are the Stan-Stans?
Is that true?
Whoever I give- Whoever I give the raptor steel to will be coming to my town.
Just wanna be sure.
Doki needs stickers more than the world needs raptors.
It's for a good cause.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Come on!
Is that true?
Like, whoever I talk to would come to my town?
Let Vess be independent.
Yeah, but why would I have to talk to both of them?
Oh, oh, they both make it?
You just choose in the end?
Okay guys, they both make it, but I'll make the poll now in advance.
We must fix the gender imbalance.
Stan...
The man...
Vess...
The woman...
I don't know.
I don't know what else to call her.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright guys, here's your poll.
Vess the best.
Vess the last.
Okay.
Alright.
Here, will this Piraptor scale work?
Oh, geez.
You actually got me one.
Yeah.
What?
I feel bad, but...
I was hoping you'd get it.
I was hoping you wouldn't find any, so we could call this thing off.
And forget about any of us going to another town.
So that was your plan.
How dare you!
Since you brought one, I've got to do my job.
I worked so hard killing off a species to make them endangered?
I'll make my best raptor steal yet.
Stan's kinda annoying.
There.
Done.
This is why Vess is winning.
The raptor steal Norris taught me to make.
One look at that tells me how skilled a craftsman your father must have been.
And it seems the apple hasn't fallen far from the tree.
It's always nice to hear Pop get compliments.
I'm pretty sure I'll win this.
But it's all in your hands now.
Alright, let's see what Vess will say.
Alright.
Alright, let's see what Vess says.
Vess will appreciate me more.
Yes!
That's it!
Thank you for the super chat.
Now I can get started.
Thank you.
Who would win?
A million years of evolution or one tank?
Let's see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Hey, are you sure about this?
Oh hey, Vess doesn't know how to make this guys.
Like...
Guys!
It's her first time making raptors steal.
Are you still on Vess?
Oh, but don't worry, okay?
If my tank falls apart because we got Vess and she does not know quality control.
I swear to God.
I watched Stan make it before.
How are we supposed to not worry?
Anyway, I'll get right to it.
So wish me luck.
Good luck.
Here, check it out.
Oh, it's a good thing.
I did good, right?
Guys, guys.
It doesn't look like it's your first time.
Oh, shit, Ral!
That's so out of context.
Maybe to the untrained eye.
Give that here.
Look closely.
Scratch it a little with a tool.
And...
What?
And what?
Huh?
Guys, the plating came right off, guys!
Guys!
My tank falls apart!
No way!
Why?
I bet you forgot to treat the base metal surface.
Give her a chance, Doki!
Skip that step and the plating will come right off.
She literally skipped the step, guys!
It just slipped my mind, is all.
Please...
Give me another chance.
Sure, why not?
Okay, she sucks, but hear me out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Do it as many times as you need.
She needs training.
Who's gonna train her?
We're picking one person!
Thanks!
I'll need more skills then.
She needs me to kill off more raptors!
So she can get better!
Right.
Well...
Guess we have to get more.
I have to get more?
Guys, I have to get more skills because of her.
Here you go.
This is training, Doki.
I'll get started right away!
Thank god I had enough.
Thank god.
There!
Done!
Okay, what about this?
Girl cute.
Scrooge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But the plating is not coming off this time.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
Stan's gonna be like, I'm actually her.
See?
I'm actually her.
Stan?
Hmm...
Don't you think about the population?
Hey demon buddy.
You confident in your strength?
Of course I am.
Who do you take me for?
Then can you try bending this steel with all your strength?
No matter how strong he is, it's impossible.
I'm the fiend prince Beelzebub.
Don't doubt my strength.
Huh?
Did I bend it?
I did it!
I cracked it!
No way.
Guys!
How is that possible?
If we f**king used her raptor steel to upgrade my tank.
My tank is gonna get bent in half.
What temperature did we do the heat treatment at?
About 520 degrees Fahrenheit.
But she's learning Doki!
It doesn't count!
He's learning Goku too!
If I was Goku too, I would not be using a tank to kill everything.
What is he doing?
Stan is just trying to teach her.
If I had Stan, I wouldn't have to teach her anything because I could just leave her in this village.
That's true.
I already killed off the population in that cave.
I might as well.
Just have them marry... They're fucking brother and sister!
Musa... Musa, do you want to change your answer, Musa?
Do you want to change your answer?
I'll give up on going to Spino.
It's done.
This is the apocalypse not nitpicking?
We just discovered water!
It's not even an apocalypse!
It's the one guy that was like, I'm gonna tax the water!
Like, we literally discovered water!
It's not even an apocalypse anymore!
It's pretty much...
Oh my god, wait, she is a prodigy!
What the fuck?
Wait, dragoons!
This guy took years to learn this!
Wait a minute!
Guys, wait!
Was she actually a prodigy?
Guys, I told you guys.
I knew we had to just...
We had to just nurture her until she became even better than her brother.
I fucking called it.
I always believed in you!
I always believed in you, Vess!
She was just an unpolished rock, Crystal.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it!
We have to give another one to Vess?
No, I just... Okay.
Alright, Stan, what do you want?
Both our raptor steels are ready.
Win or lose, no grudges.
Please speak to the person you want in Spino.
Oh, okay.
Got it.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
I don't know.
He literally said that it's better than...
Guys, I knew it.
She was just an unpolished diamond, guys.
She was an unpolished diamond and we polished her.
So now... So now she's gonna... She's gonna be the one.
I knew it.
Are you sure you want me?
Of course, Vess!
Of course!
It was always you, Vess.
You're younger than Stan and like...
Yeah, Diamond, you're younger than Stan.
But like your first try only... It only took four... Actually, your fourth try.
It nearly only took four tries to be better than him.
So of course, Vess.
Of course, I want you in my town.
I beat Stan.
You did, girl!
You beat him!
You were always my first choice, Vess.
You...
You were always my first choice.
I needed a second chance.
And a second second chance.
But you chose me.
So I'll do my best not to disappoint you.
Maester, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not fair.
Stan is unaware because his favorite rapper didn't respond to his letters.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nah, Stan just sucks.
He didn't notice since there's not many Blacks in this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Still impulsive and unreliable.
Oh, shit.
You've got talent.
Wait, what do you mean unreliable?
Stan, you did not let me read the fine print.
Stan!
What do you mean unreliable?
Guys, can I get a refund?
I can't fix it.
I'm sure she'll surpass me someday.
It's your problem now.
Guys, what the fuck does he mean unreliable?
Stan!
Right before she passed, mom asked, I hope I was able to fulfill her dying wish.
Now she is your problem.
Dang it.
Now is not the time to be getting all gloomy.
Guys...
It's our last night.
I've got to be cheerful for her sake.
Guys, I don't know what he meant by that.
He didn't explain anything to me.
Now I'm a little worried.
Yeah!
I'm a craftsman now!
You made the choice, Turkey.
Now live with it.
Cause I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
You're gonna be seeing a lot more of me from now on.
Well, the moment I'm fucking finally able to decorate my tank, like, I'm gone.
I'm fucking gone from this town.
We're never coming back here.
Oh, you're Tor.
Back here again, I see.
Zep wants to talk to you.
Something about furniture?
Ah, yes.
Apologies.
When looking out from this spot, I can feel the town's vitality.
I suppose that's why I seem to find myself here all the time.
I think I understand.
Though we've still a ways to go.
Being able to watch the town change before our eyes.
Yeah, sorry that I didn't do this until now, guys.
Sorry to my town.
Sorry, Mayor.
I could have done this a long time ago.
Can we order a few pieces?
Cease this publicity effort.
I don't know about that.
Bro, what the fuck?
That's an adult voice coming out of this child.
This kid fucking hit puberty.
What the hell?
I don't think any of the people I talked to ended up moving here.
That is not a child.
If anyone deserves credit, it's you, Prince.
He's just short and ducky.
There's no right or wrong in the now to tell them the truth.
Fine.
Not like I did it for them anyways.
I'm just in it for making our bots stronger.
In that case, we're going to need an EX chip store if we don't want their power plateauing.
Materials and Anne's knowledge alone will only get us so far.
Yeah, guess so.
Well, back to work I go.
I can't believe it.
Finally, this town has three women.
Or two because we're taking one of them away.
To Greenland.
Furniture!
Oh my god!
My fifty chairs!
It's time!
Now that you mention it, other townsfolk had similar grievances.
The more people come, the more necessities arise, I suppose.
It's time!
Such is the way of things.
There's no sure sign that vitality has returned to speed.
After three weeks, my fifty chairs are useful!
I'm so happy.
Now is the time for action.
Spino shall shine once more.
Looks like your vitality's returned too, Mayor.
Isn't that great, Hugh?
Yup.
Oh my god.
It's time!
A new workshop has opened.
At Workshop, you can process ores and materials collected from hunting into necessary items for modding your vehicles.
Also, check out the Workshop when you have a hard time finding a certain item.
How do I decorate?
Oh my god, guys!
There's actual bridges now!
Holy shit!
The town is actually different!
Great.
Another failure.
What?
Bess?
Don't make me regret this decision!
Hey, Bess.
What are you up to?
You got eyes, right?
Yeah.
But that doesn't mean I know what I'm looking at.
I'm working on material processing to grow our lineup.
Yeah, god damn you!
We just walked in!
What do you mean, Bess?
You just witnessed me ruining some of my most prized materials!
Yours?
Didn't I give you some of the materials?
I bet my brother wouldn't be struggling like this.
Oh, Bess.
You're... I don't know about this now.
Now you're making...
Saying these things is sort of making me regret the decisions right now.
It's literally day one.
It's not looking good.
Hey!
I know when someone's spacing out on me.
You know, if I improve my skills and our shop's lineup grows...
You'll be able to make your vehicles stronger.
Yeah, but Sam would have known these were...
These things already, though.
Wait, for real?
Sam would have known already!
The better the materials, the better they should perform.
I knew you'd like that.
I have a proposal... request.
There's a merchant named Kuo whom I know from my Taobo days.
Could you ask him to come to Spino?
Another one?
Wait, are you trying to get someone to come over here?
To like, make up for your lack of experience?
Like, I just got Stan!
He's a peddler.
Won't he turn up eventually?
What do you mean by that?
What?
I have you know...
I found two other citizens to tax today.
So he only swings by when he feels like it.
My town is perfectly profitable.
I'm not going to be a peddler.
The materials I ruined just now are pretty rare.
Kuo's the only person I know who has them.
So please!
He's been obsessed with racing lately.
He's probably near the Lysab race track.
There's a race track?
Fine.
I guess it's worth it to power up our bots.
But I don't even know what he looks like.
Oh, that won't be a problem.
What does he look like?
He's a bit hard of hearing.
You'll know him right away from his booming voice.
I feel like he'd be like the only peddler there.
Guess that'll work.
I'll be...
Thanks!
I'll get my tools polished up and ready to go!
Do you need to race him?
Well...
It's fun that you guys think I'm gonna do it.
I only have one goal in mind here.
Can I put stickers now?
Is it time?
Ann!
Hello!
Wait, okay, I'm not talking about you, Polack.
Do you need anything?
Ann!
Can I...
Can I decorate my vehicle now?
Customize?
No!
See you later!
When can I...
Oh, other side quest.
Oh my god, this guy.
The soldier.
He must be able to let me customize my stuff.
The other soldier!
Come over here.
Man, what am I gonna do?
I can't take on monsters.
Then that's why you live in my town.
Where?
You don't have to deal with any of that work bullshit anymore.
Nice shrink.
What do you find scarier?
Fiends or monsters?
Oh, well I'm used to you now, Beelzebub.
Yes.
Anyhow, what's this about monsters?
Sorry, I have to live with it for a bit longer.
I have to still live in this village?
If you go through, you can hear them growl from the cliffs.
Peddlers are too scared to go through there now, I hear.
If that rumor spreads, merchants might stop coming to town.
No!
Merchants already stopped coming to the town because we're poor, Ralph!
We're fucking poor!
So now it's my job to stamp the monsters out.
But just because I'm an ex-soldier doesn't mean I'm a one-man army.
What does that make me?
I'm the one-man army.
So why did you take on a monster hunting job in the first place?
Well, I recently took on another job from a peddler.
He had bought up too much cargo, you see?
So the job was to keep it safe until he came back.
Which I was more than happy to do.
So...
I accepted the job immediately.
But when the peddler left, he joked...
Don't you go selling any of that out from under me now.
And, well, that gave me ideas.
No, soldiers should not have ideas, Moss.
Moss, no no no.
A good soldier follows.
I am just putting it all for peanuts to some random traveler.
Oh yeah, never mind.
You should definitely stop having ideas, Moss.
You're a little stupid.
You've really gotta work on that habit of yours.
Cool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At least she is pretty, Tom Boy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I said I'd do anything to make it up.
Turns out anything is go drive away hordes of monsters.
Moss, how could you?
Sounds like just desserts, honestly.
Beat up monsters?
Sounds like a good time to me.
Then be my guest.
If there really are monsters, that is.
And if so, yeah, beat them up if you can.
Oh my god.
Moss, please.
What do you mean?
Beat up the monsters?
Just give me the paint.
Let me use my chair.
That's the quest.
Time to beat up some monsters.
Alright.
Self-tape.
Is this one?
Light on the hilltop?
Is that the quest?
Mysterious voice.
I've never seen this one before.
It has to be this one, right?
Okay.
Alright.
Let's grab my motorcycle.
Mysterious voice?
Oh, mysterious voice is the quest?
Okay, JK.
We don't care about you anymore.
Is this a waypoint?
Oh, I can.
I can just travel.
Alright.
Oh my god, this is it.
This is it!
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
Hello?
We found those monsters?
That sounds promising.
Who's that?
We must be getting pretty close.
What?
He disappeared.
Oh, we have to find him.
Oh, but there's loot here.
Where is he?
We have to find him?
Wait, there's something over here.
There's a green thing over here.
Oh no, that's just more gems.
JK.
That's just more gems.
Did you use a jump bot?
Oh, because of this?
So much sand flowing in.
Where does it go from here?
Wait, I can jump this.
Who knows?
Okay, never mind.
It's a mystery.
A mystery far beyond our understanding.
Maybe we'll know in a thousand years.
Alright, guys.
I was just thinking.
Maybe I should start saving.
I was like...
I feel like...
Sorry for the...
For that.
I feel like...
I don't know how much the side quest saves.
So I'm going to start saving now.
Sorry, guys.
Oh, are you the mysterious voice?
Why are you scared?
Hey, that voice.
Wait, the monsters were just you groaning?
That was you?
Somebody help me.
Is that how you fucking cry?
Take it easy.
You're all right now.
Nerd.
Wait, you're...
You know this guy, old man?
No.
I'm sorry, but I don't recognize him.
Hey, who are you?
You wouldn't.
We met over 20 years ago.
Oh, when he was a baby.
I was scared stiff up on a high place then, too.
And you saved me.
Wait, you're not that boy, Shion, are you?
That's him.
That's right.
I was crying so much that I didn't get a chance to thank you.
I always regretted that.
And I hoped I'd get another chance.
I'm glad we got that chance.
What did he get up to?
Shion from 20 years ago?
How about we get him down from there before you two start catching up?
How did he get up here, though?
If he's so scared of heights?
Seems like I got down in one piece.
Thank you.
So, what are you up to these days?
Well, I've become a painter.
Oh my God!
I'm still just an apprentice, though.
Let's fucking go!
You sure have grown up.
No wonder I couldn't peg you as that kid who would start crying at the drop of a hat.
This is it!
I may not be a child anymore, but I'm still just as much of a scaredy cat.
Shion, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
By the way, light on the hilltop unlocks furniture!
Okay, we're doing the furniture one next.
What about you, Mr. R?
You can mash the OK button when deploying a vehicle.
Jump into it instantly.
From what I can see...
You're on the road with some demon friends?
You got some beef with demons.
Yeah, you got some beef there.
Chairs?
What the fuck is wrong with him?
Prince, knock it off.
We're currently traveling using Spino as our base of operations.
Spino?
I've never been.
Oh, you're gonna love it here.
I hope you like paying taxes, too.
I'm not a work in progress, but it's a good town.
You know, I've been looking for a place to settle down.
Oh my god, another one.
If it's good enough for you, then I'm sure it is for me.
Guys, unfortunately we have imbalanced the towns.
We always have the welcome mat out.
We might have a town imbalance again, guys.
Trust me, demons aren't as fearsome as you've heard.
Are you sure?
Well, they don't look that scary.
So, maybe?
Come on, old man.
You're killing my rep here.
Sorry.
Then my mind's made up.
I'm moving to Spino.
I don't think he's a threat in that...
What are you trying to say?
He can get a woman?
As soon as I pick up my belongings, I'll head right there.
Some women like nerds?
Out there?
I don't know about the ones in my town, but like...
One of them might.
I will.
See you.
He's a painter.
Just like Leonardo DiCaprio from Titanic.
Guys, that guy got women.
He painted one like the French girls.
You can't say that.
Oh, Ron.
What do you mean, Ron?
He was a bad painter.
But he's hot.
Hey, his painting skills helped out.
Counterpoint means DiCaprio.
Here we go.
There's hope for...
Alright.
We gotta go get that furniture too.
We gotta get that furniture.
And then he...
Look, we're not talking about the fact that he died.
We're talking about the fact that like...
That he did get it.
Oh, wait.
You're not what I wanted to...
You're not the quest I needed to do.
So I'm sorry.
I like how like in the distance I hear him yell for help.
Sorry.
You're not that important.
I'm sorry.
What?
Wait, you can get me off the fucking motorcycle?
Okay.
I was like running over scorpions thinking I can like...
I don't have to care.
Alright.
Do be careful, Prince.
It's fine.
We can ride past this.
Oh, there you go.
Furniture is here.
Leave him to get eaten.
Look, I'm sorry.
It just wasn't as important.
We gotta...
We gotta get the furniture unlocked.
Wait!
Guys!
We fixed the problem instantly!
Do you see something in the sky?
Something flashed on that hill over there.
I'd love to know what it is.
But I can't see anything from here.
I've got an idea.
How about I climb on your shoulders?
Wait, what?
Wait.
Are you...
A demon?
Scared you?
I've never been so shocked.
You're the first one I've ever seen in my life.
Oh my god, Megabear Muse?
She's also an artist too!
I told you guys!
There's hope for everybody!
Even better.
We're gonna play matchmaker.
I can't believe you're up to that.
I'm a fan of you as an artist.
Demons really are something else.
This girl is a total weirdo.
I'm outta here.
I'm afraid I can't let you.
What?
I want to draw you.
Wait, what?
And you're not going anywhere till I do.
I don't feel comfortable with this.
Excuse me?
I'd love to get started right away.
But I'm the type to do things one at a time.
Huh?
Which means...
I can't wait for her.
She's weird.
...first order of business is gone.
But I'd be ill to see what that light was.
Could you wait for me?
I should be back in three days.
Wait, wait.
Three days?
We need you in the town now.
I feel like we'd sit around and wait that long.
Oh, what to do, what to do?
It'd be faster if I had a vehicle that could jump high.
Anyway, you can't leave until I've investigated that light.
Understood?
I'm sorry.
Oh, I don't need anything for furniture.
I can't draw you until I've checked it out, right?
And I won't let you leave until I have.
So you're stuck here.
Oh my gosh, she's so assertive.
This really is a bit of a pickle.
I'll never understand just what goes on inside artist's heads.
Oh, I know!
You can go check it out for me and tell me what it is.
Oh, that's a lot easier.
The mystery will be solved.
I have a jump bot too!
Then you'll be free to leave.
Yeah, it's a win-win for everyone.
Yay!
You just have lint floating around in the head of yours.
Whoa, Beezlebub, that's so rude.
Oh!
Just because she's a freak doesn't mean she's dumb.
How about you open it up and take a look for me?
Ugh!
You're grossing me out.
Well, it seems we have no choice but to do as she asked.
Fine.
I'll check that hill for you.
Guys, Beezlebub, please think about the furniture, Beezlebub.
I promise you'll get off my back once I do.
Think about the furniture!
Woohoo!
And that 50 chairs!
I promise!
Come to think of it, I haven't introduced myself.
I'm Luteimus, a craftsman.
How about you, Beezlebub?
Whoa!
He's a child!
Yellzebub.
He might be like a 500-year-old child, but like he's still a child.
He's been killed in demon years.
Yellzebub!
Oh, even your name is beautiful!
Whoa!
Get away from her!
Oh my god.
We gotta go up here.
Okay, we have the jump bot.
Uh...
It's time.
Boom.
Alright, lady.
We have a painter nerd just for you.
We just recruited one.
Don't worry.
We're gonna play matchmaker for her.
Is it?
Is it this?
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Alright.
We found the treasure.
It had nothing.
I was glinting off it.
It was already looted.
Whoa!
A treasure chest?
There wasn't even anything in there.
The world sure is full of wonders.
That means treasure could be at the top of other hills too!
Well, the only treasure for me right now is...
Whoa!
No!
I don't know if I want her in my town anymore, guys.
I think we might have a problem.
Wow!
Bezebub, no!
You don't... don't... what's the wait?
Don't incur... don't enable her!
Bezebub, don't enable her!
Wow!
Bro!
What the fuck is wrong with her?
Are you kidding me?
No way you're coming with us!
My vote is a no too!
Yeah, no!
No, I'm sorry!
Guys, we can't... guys, we can't let her in!
What?!
What the fuck, run her!
Run her!
Oh my god!
I guess.
But you can't live there!
Yeah, no, don't let her live there!
Don't let her live there!
Right!
Spino!
They're looking for new residents!
No!
Bezebub!
I don't think legally she's allowed to!
Got it!
I was looking for a place to set up my real trade.
Furniture making.
So this is perfect.
No, no, no, no!
I have this town with you and it is better than perfect.
I'll head there at once!
Oh my god!
Shit!
What the fuck?!
Holy shit!
This won't stop!
Don't make eye contact and just keep walking!
Just keep walking, Bezebub!
Never!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh shit!
It's stranger danger!
You don't meet someone that troublesome every day!
Finally, cheers!
Guys!
Guys, I don't know if furniture was worth it in the end!
Guys, finally, cheers!
But at what cost?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Ninja!
Well, Doki, you got your wish!
You can use your chairs now!
Guys!
We have chairs now!
We have chairs!
Nice!
This is one picturesque town!
Have a feeling I won't be bored around here!
You now have a room!
Your room is locked in the garage in Spino!
Get furniture to- Okay, we are not coming!
We are not going to fucking- Guys!
We have a room though!
Guys!
We did it!
Oh my god!
We're not going to go near that woman!
But guys!
We have a room!
Do you need anything?
Yes.
Where's my room?
Wait, how do I get to my room?
Is my room still locked?
When does it get unlocked?
Oh my god, the town does look better!
But the chairs...
Oh, it's in the back of the garage!
Okay.
So like...
Wait, what?
Go around the back.
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Oh, there's free stuff.
I'm around it.
Where the fuck is my room?
Oh, to the back inside!
Guys, it's okay.
As long as we never...
You know... go near her, we're fine.
Where the fuck?
Where's my room?
The shutter?
Where the fuck is my room?
No!
Anne,
where's my room?
Anne!
Maybe talk... No, we're not gonna talk to her!
We're not...
Guys, we're not gonna talk to her, guys!
What about the other guy?
Wasn't there the painter guy?
Okay.
You might have to... No, okay.
Alright.
It's alright.
We'll be fine.
Heya, Beelzebub!
This is a nice town.
Full of inspiration.
I think I'll make good furniture here.
You'll like my work, too.
Here, try putting this in your space and see if it fits.
Oh, and please spare me some time to dry you.
I'm busy right now.
Another time.
Oh my god, she had the key!
That's so fucked up.
She had the key all along.
Alright, let's get the paint as well.
Oh my god, this town is looking like actually pretty.
It only took two hours.
Hey, good to see you, yes?
How'd the monster thing turn out?
I did it.
Piece of cake.
One hand tied behind your back, huh?
That's our Beelzebub!
Actually, there weren't any monsters at all.
Just a human.
Yeah, just a nerd.
He was stuck up a cliff making all sorts of weird noises.
I can see why they freak people out so much.
To my surprise, it was Shion, an old acquaintance of mine.
He's moving to Spino.
Treat him right, would you?
Understood, yes!
What is his job anyway?
Everybody else has a job, but he's just there.
Thanks again!
I should be squared away with that peddler now.
Try not to stick your foot in it next time, okay?
Y-you know you're just giving me ideas.
He's definitely gonna get into trouble again.
He's a one-man army doki.
Oh, the painter's here!
Raul was right.
Spino really does seem like a lovely place.
We're finally gonna have color!
Oh
god!
We can put decals!
Okay, we're gonna cut- oh my god, finally.
We finally did it!
I'm gonna decorate the room that I'll never come back to after I leave Sandland.
But this is it, finally!
It has- all these side quests has led to this one moment.
Oh my god.
Wait, why did Anne have like a...
Why did Anne have that thing on top of her head?
So like...
Like why did she have like a little thingy pop up?
Make part- oh, it's cause of the parts!
I see!
Okay.
There we go, move.
There we go.
Oh my god, finally.
You can personalize your room by using press to open- you can place the furniture from the room.
Oh my god!
The room layout.
Select the- GUYS!
Did you guys see the fifty?
Guys!
I can finally use my fifty fucking chairs!
Oh my god!
Oh, it's finally here!
I'm so happy!
It's finally here!
I finally- Oh my god!
It's finally here guys!
My fifty chairs!
Okay.
Choose to select.
Um, selecting a- We need some virtual life!
Please!
We finally did it!
Oh my god!
This is everything we wanted!
And more!
I can't believe it.
Holy shit.
Where the fuck is my chairs?
Oh!
Oh my god!
There it is!
We finally did it!
Oh my god.
Oh this is all I wanted to do.
Finally!
Oh my god.
Holy shit!
This is actually everything we wanted!
I can finally place my 50 chairs!
Yay!
Oh my god, I can put chairs here too?!
Oh!
Here we go!
Nice.
Okay.
Woah, what the fuck?
Okay, and then two sofas too.
Okay, nice.
Alright, and then just place only chairs.
Here we go!
We did it!
We got our chairs!
Oh my god, we finally got our chairs, guys!
All it took was 200 side quests!
All it took...
Okay, and then we'll put...
There we go.
Nice.
And then we should grab...
Wait, we can put a... Oh shit, we can put a car in here?!
Oh my god, let's put bed of dragoons.
Let's put a scam.
We'll put dragoon in here.
We'll put a car in here too.
Fuck it.
We have space, right?
Do we have space for the dragoon?
There we go.
Look at this feng shui!
Look at that.
You know what?
Decor.
Alright, what is the decor gonna be like?
Okay.
I can't believe it.
I knew it wasn't a myth, guys.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it was real!
You guys just thought I was crazy!
I knew.
I knew my chairs were real.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking... No, I'm gonna get rid of all the sofas and just keep the chairs.
Let's see.
Edit furniture.
Okay, how do I make sure to get rid of this?
Alright, we're gonna get rid of like the non...
We're gonna...
Okay.
We're gonna get rid of the sofas.
Remove.
It should be... It should just be like the chairs.
The sofas and...
Yeah, let's get rid of...
Let's get rid of the hideout beds too.
And then...
We don't need beds here.
We have our chairs.
So...
Alright, we're gonna get rid of the...
We're gonna get rid of all the sofas.
Because this is just a chair home.
You know?
This is right... No, no!
See?
We're just getting rid of all the sofas.
Okay, yep.
Alright.
Is that everything?
No, there's still more.
How is there still more?
How...
Oh my god, you're right.
Sorry, I had 50 sofas.
I was like...
How do I still have more?
Oh right!
50 sofas.
Now I remember how I still have more.
There we go.
Me and my chairs.
Okay.
This shit is beautiful.
Oh my god, it's a beautiful customized color.
Ooh!
Decor color!
Okay.
Basic flooring.
Make it yellow.
And then we'll make the furniture colors too.
We gotta change the furniture color.
Oh my!
We are not changing!
Okay.
One of them.
You get to be special.
The one green chair.
I'm not changing every chair, guys.
I'm not doing every fucking chair.
But like...
This chair.
This chair is special.
Oh, we're getting rid of the cars.
Actually.
Let's get rid of the car.
Sorry, man.
I just realized...
It just doesn't fit.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, guys.
I know you love to be in this room.
But like...
Honestly...
Who put this one white chair here?
What the fuck are you doing here?
But it was worth it.
My 50...
Holy shit!
I went to get a drink.
What happened?
We have our room, guys.
We have our room!
We did it.
Guys.
Our feng shui is off the roof right now.
There's a chair among us.
Oh my god.
After everything, we finally...
This is why I pre-ordered Sand Land.
This is exactly why I pre-ordered Sand Land.
It was so worth it, guys.
Finally!
The pre-order was worth it.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I can finally put stickers.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Look at all these colors!
Alright.
What do I...
What?
Okay.
Yellow.
It has to be bright yellow so people will know I'm coming.
So they'll know.
They'll know I'm heading over.
Oh.
Okay.
And then we'll put...
Oh!
We'll put blue like the hat?
And then what's this?
Okay.
And then the...
The legs.
Where's the legs?
What is this?
Oh.
Option one.
Okay.
The legs.
Oh wait.
No.
Never mind.
This looks ugly.
Okay.
What?
Decal!
Oh my god!
We can change our decal!
Guys!
Now they'll never...
If only I could have changed it earlier and put 105 so people will know it's me.
Oh!
There's art too!
There's logos!
And then there's like...
Oh there's actual numbers!
Oh my god!
Okay.
I want to put art on it.
Wait.
Where can...
Can I put it anywhere?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm gonna put...
Oh my god.
We could be like...
Oh!
There's a B.
There's so many choices.
What is this?
Fucking basketball?
Like what?
This looks like a basketball logo.
Okay.
Uh.
Alright.
We're gonna do...
Oh I wanna be...
I wanna be a...
Oh my god.
There's so many choices.
Wait.
There's a blue bird?
Where's the blue bird?
Oh you're right!
There is!
Wait.
Where is it?
Where does the decal go?
Where does it go?
Wait.
I have to pay for this?
Okay.
That's fucked up.
Not gonna lie.
Where's the decal?
My equipment may be hiding the decal?
Oh my god.
That's fucked up.
That's actually fucked up.
No!
Oh my god.
I'll make sure everything has...
I'll make sure...
Okay.
We're just gonna put it there.
What the fuck.
Where are you?
No more eyes for you.
You don't get eyes anymore.
You don't get eyes.
I need this decal somewhere.
If it's the last...
Oh shit.
No.
That's now why I wanted...
I need...
I need it somewhere if it's the last thing I do.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, and then...
Can I just hold it?
Painting...
Yes!
I want that.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe my decal didn't even show up anywhere.
Like, where the fuck you're...
I'm not gonna make this... I'm not gonna make the tank naked!
I worked so hard to put this...
I worked so hard!
To get to this stage!
Alright, alright.
We just have...
It's okay.
This is all I wanted.
There we go.
It's beautiful.
You're beautiful.
You're so beautiful.
Okay.
Is that it?
Do I just have to...
Painting...
Painted.
Okay.
Did I do it?
I must have done it, right?
Yeah!
Everything's good!
Alright.
It's beautiful.
Oh my god!
Finally!
Alright.
Everything else, I really don't care.
See you!
Alright.
Goodbye, town.
I worked so hard.
It only took two hours, guys.
But we can finally leave.
It only took two hours.
And go to Greenland.
Oh my god.
Here we go!
Off to Greenland we go.
It was a journey.
We're off to Greenland.
Did I go the wrong way for Greenland?
Fuck.
How do I get there?
Oh my god.
We're finally gonna see the greens, guys.
We're fi- Oh my god, wait, we have to kill him!
We gotta make sure his- we keep- this species go endangered!
Guys, it's a rare raptor!
It's the P-Raptor!
Alright, we're just gonna- oh my god.
Oh my god, Joki tanked in action.
We'll let this guy live.
We'll let the child live.
The last white- it's like the last unicorn!
But better, because I'm the one doing the kill- In game, in game.
In game.
Dark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This room reminds me of your dad's- of your old Minecraft clip where your inventory was- No!
I was reading super chat.
But I can- there's no web.
Are you serious?
We're sinking into the water.
This won't work!
Oh my god.
Maybe finding- this was a mistake.
Giving them water was a mistake.
I should never have given them water.
Where your inventory is so unorganized and destroy the OCD.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Weeeee!
Okay.
I hope I'm going the right way with this.
I went the wrong way?
God damn it!
I went the wrong way.
I was supposed to hold- hold- wait, no, did I?
Gosh, where is the- oh, I could just- I should have just fast traveled there.
Giving the people water was a mistake.
Okay, this way.
Alright, now I'm closer.
Yeah!
I'm closer now.
Guys, we have to head to Greenland.
That's like our end goal.
After everything.
After all the quests we did.
We have to progress the story.
Alright, that peddler's gonna die.
Immortal Joe was right.
Oh no, my nitro.
Discord nitro, where are you?
You know they don't.
Guys, okay, so like...
In the past...
In the past, Discord used to give out free nitro to content creators.
So like, I thought they still do that.
So I was like, hey, do you guys still give out free nitro?
They're like, I'm sorry, Doki, we don't do that anymore.
Hahaha!
It doesn't hurt to ask!
Like, they used to!
Oh shit!
In the old days.
So now I pay for my own nitro.
I'm just like you guys.
See?
I'm one with the people.
Guys, it was a choice.
I'm with the people.
Just like all of you.
I pay for my own nitro.
Stay with us.
Can you speak?
Tell us what happened.
I...
I don't know.
What happened?
Sorry, I...
Sorry, I was like...
Gone for a long time.
I know like one of your soldiers might have died because like I never came back.
But after, you know, fixing up my town for...
In two hours...
Hahaha!
Now I'm here to actually do this quest.
Some thieves had snuck onto the ship to raid the place.
While we were chasing them, a mysterious armed group suddenly showed up.
Oh shit, who?
That's when the shooting started.
And at some point in all the chaos, I got hit.
Just on the arm?
When it was all over, the ship's cargo ended up in that armed group's hands.
Thieves in a mysterious armed group.
Both after the ship's cargo?
What did the ship's cargo have?
Oh my god, did you guys see that one guy just lying on the ground dead?
How long has this...
Haha!
Did you see that guy?
How long has he been dead for?
Oh my gosh, I've been gone for a while.
Oh shit, I'm sorry man.
Hahaha!
Look, I'm sorry.
I had to paint my tank.
And get chairs.
Somebody help!
I'm...
I'm not with the Royalists!
Calm yourself!
We're on your side!
You are?
Oh!
Oh, thank god he's alive!
Did he just faint from relief?
Oh my god, maybe he shouldn't be a soldier.
What's this about Royalists?
Yeah, who are the Royalists?
Hello?
Sandland soldier?
Oh no!
I don't wanna die!
Don't be a little bitch!
Get up!
Just sit tight!
Your wound isn't lethal!
What wound?
Hahaha!
General Shiva!
Are you here to save us?
That armed group that attacked you.
Where'd they go?
Yeah, where'd they go?
They split up.
Half headed north and the other half south.
Our leader gathered anyone who could fight and raced south.
What in the world happened here?
Yeah!
No idea.
In any case, let's get in touch with Ahri.
Okay.
That wound that's definitely dead.
He's not really there but can't show it to us.
He's doing the football.
The soccer strat.
They got caught between a band of thieves and some armed group.
Thieves and bandits?
Who could they have been?
Yeah, how could they steal from us?
We just got water back!
But the other groups are mystery.
One soldier alluded to being mistaken for a Royalist.
The fuck is a Royalist?
General R?
It's possible.
That term refers to close allies of Zeyu and the King.
Maybe the attackers mistook the battleship guards for Royalists.
Which means they had a grudge against Zeyu.
Makes sense.
We're going after the armed group that fled to the north.
Could you get in touch with the unit that headed south?
Understood.
I'll lead a unit myself as well.
If things go well, we can pincer the group that fled north.
Alright, let's beat the shit out of them.
Sounds good.
I'll be in touch.
They can't steal from me.
I'm here to steal.
Thanks for your cooperation.
Why did we just offer to go after a bunch of people we know are armed to the teeth?
Because we have a tank.
We can't let some unidentified armed group roam around freely.
Yeah.
I can't believe this.
Here you go again.
Dragging us into danger.
How can we find them when all we know is they went north?
That's good enough for me.
Here we go.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah!
Don't worry.
I know I can never get lost.
Okay, where's North?
Don't worry.
There's only one way I can go in this path.
How can I get lost now?
So when does the green start getting green?
See?
I know where North is.
It's this way.
What other way could it be?
Start by observing them carefully.
Knowing what they can do and what their weaknesses are will help you fight a...
Is this this way?
Give me a sec, guys.
Is it?
It has to be this way.
I'll try that next time.
Wait, where else am I supposed to go?
Wait, what?
And you go back?
Guys.
I might have went the wrong way.
Guys, I know which way is the right way.
I'm going to go this way.
I never get lost.
It's okay.
I'm never lost.
Guys...
I went the right way.
I just wanted to look at the dam.
Just wanted to do a little sightseeing.
Okay, there's an open door.
I would assume we go through this door because we've never been there.
I didn't know we have to stay in Sand Land.
I thought we're gonna go to Green Land.
Oh, and then we follow this.
Yeah, see?
We just follow this.
It's just that easy.
Nice.
Look, see?
We just follow these tracks.
Follow the yellow... giant yellow mark there.
Thank God they put yellow here.
Look, we're doing it.
We're just following the...
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, who killed these dinos and it's not me?
Wait, they actually died?
Oh my God, wait.
There's death in this game?
Wait, what?
Maybe they tried attacking the armed group and paid the price.
Holy shit!
They actually killed.
Oh my God, there's several dead dinos here.
Guys, every time I try to kill, they just run away.
And being like, ooh, they're just fainted.
Or, oh, they just got lost.
Doki's just annoyed someone's taking her job.
The forever E.
I can't believe it.
There's so many dead dinos!
We should keep our distance from the army base unless necessary.
You're taking my job!
I bet they've got loads of loot in there!
Can't argue with that.
Oh shit!
Somehow I doubt they'd take my meeting with shooters...
Placoon here.
This will be my last super chat for the stream.
Aziah, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Thank you for all the help, too.
Forestland is four dungeon crawls and one mandatory vehicle build away!
Have fun!
You mean I'm not going to head to Greenland?
I don't want to go to Greenland!
Greenland is four dungeons away!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No!
I can't clickbait you guys!
Guys, no!
We can't!
No, I would have clickbaited you guys if I don't head to Greenland!
Guys, no!
I swear I'm not here to clickbait you guys!
We're gonna be in Greenland!
He said off to Greenland, not that you'll be there.
Oh shit, you're right.
Oh shit.
No!
Don't destroy me!
I literally just made the city!
Oh my god, that's so fucked up.
No, I swear to god, I literally just made the town.
I swear to god.
Oh, it's still okay.
Oh, thank god.
I would have been so mad if they destroyed Spino.
I was freaking out for nothing.
Not that it's like a worry to me.
I worked so hard on those chairs.
We should check in with her, just to make sure everything is alright.
Alright.
Broku, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Alright, Anne.
Wait, not Anne?
Polack?
Welcome back, everyone.
Hey, guys.
It's just you?
Where's Anne?
Yeah, where's Anne?
She went off to the Leesop Junker Market.
To do some bargain hunting.
Alone?
Without us?
But she's a...
She said the army is not our enemy anymore.
She's a gadget in our Chip and Dale group.
I see.
Everybody needs one gadget.
Oh.
Wait, what?
What?
It's a bit noisy out there.
I wonder what's going on.
That's the Junker from...
I think it's coming from the town's entrance.
That's the Junker from the other town.
Is he okay?
He can't be dead.
There's no dead people in this game.
Hey, are you okay?
There's apparently dead raptors.
What happened to you?
Shady guy.
Wait, he walked all the way here?
Junker's Market.
Junker's Market's so far.
They know how to fight.
It took all I had in me just to run away.
How did you run here?
Old man.
It could be the armed group.
The... the market?
But Ant's at the market now.
Yeah.
Ant's there.
He fast traveled.
You're not the only one that can fast travel, Doki.
You say that, but what do you mean?
We've got to, right?
Yeah.
He's the gadget.
She's the gadget.
Let's hurry.
So we have to find a new gadget and that's too much work.
Okay.
Or wait, Pollock's... Pollock's also a woman.
We can replace her.
We can replace her with Pollock.
Her new alien wife.
Alright, let's go.
Let's fast travel.
We can fast travel!
Oh my, that's so fucked up.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna say...
I was gonna say, are you gonna actually make me fucking walk all the way there?
I would have been so sad.
Okay, this way.
Yay.
Okay, we're gonna have to head to...
This way.
This way, right?
Am I going the right way?
Yeah.
I just don't know if I'm going the right way.
Okay.
Is everybody okay?
Is that good fire or bad fire?
Hey, they're alive.
Doesn't seem too bad.
You guys are alive!
It's you guys!
Did you come to save us?
Yeah!
I'm looking for a young woman named Anne.
No!
Did you see her?
We're only here for Anne.
A woman.
A woman?
I don't even know who you mean.
A woman.
Do you know where she is?
Yeah.
The bad guys were headed toward the Lysa battleship and she... she chased after them.
She what?
Oh my God, she's crazy.
Why did she wait for us?
Is she her mom?
Yeah.
She could have waited for us.
She's a good girl.
Okay, we got to find Anne.
Alright, off we go.
Time to find Anne.
I'm sad.
We can't use our bike yet.
Okay, now we can.
Here we go.
Alright, time to rescue Anne.
Battleship cave.
Is there people in the...
Oh shit!
I can't believe it!
A sledge stopped me?
Oh, it doesn't matter anyway.
We have to climb.
It doesn't matter.
Off we go.
We gotta climb anyway.
So far.
Why didn't we build a fast travel system in this cave?
Alright.
Give me that mat.
I need that mat.
Give me that material.
I need to upgrade our dragoon ship.
Okay.
Oh my god, I forgot how fucking tall this mountain is.
There she is!
Wait, they wear real helmets!
Where are you from?
You better stand back, doll!
Whoa!
Oh my god, they wear real uniforms compared to the ones we had to face.
Cut the crap and answer me!
Okay.
Hands off you!
Damn.
Don't make me bring the tank out.
Hey!
You guys back off too!
More!
Or what?
Look at them, thief.
They're totally scared of us!
Come on, let's have some fun with this!
Hear me, puny human!
I am the great Beelzebub!
Yeah, that's me.
Yeah, if I touch you, you die.
They don't know anything about demons.
What the fuck?
I have a tail!
Is that not scary enough?
I'm literally pink!
So what if he's a demon?
He's still just a kid.
Whoa!
Hey!
Take the girl and get lost!
If you know what's good for you.
I have horns?
Hold up.
Can you imagine what the brass bag homies say if we kill the demon?
Pink is so scary to me.
You're right.
We might even get promoted.
This is our lucky point.
I mean, he could just lie and sit at Kill Bill.
Oh shit!
Those are horns!
Sorry, it looked like hair.
It actually looked like hair.
I couldn't tell.
Watch this.
Not overkill!
Boom!
Oh yeah!
How could this block a fucking tank?
Nice.
I'm done.
A demon and his tank.
Wait.
Where are you going?
I have to do this!
Do what?
You just got here.
You don't even know what's going on, Anne!
What are you talking about?
Yeah!
Please, just let me go!
There's something I have to make sure of!
What?
Make sure of what?
She's hiding something from us.
You would hide from the team?
But we're family!
Oh, it has something to do with her necklace!
But the three of us are coming with you.
Why would you do that?
Because you're one of us.
Right, Prince?
Yeah!
You're the boomer slash gadget of the group!
Whatever.
We always need one!
But please run if it gets dangerous, okay?
Dangerous?
For me?
Come on, let's go!
Alright.
Let's go.
Dungeon number one.
What are the three dungeons?
Great.
Then where did they disappear to?
They disappeared to...
Last time we were here, we used a different exit to escape.
They probably headed in that direction.
I can't believe it.
We don't instantly head to Greenland.
We have to work for it?
This is bullshit.
Oh my god, do I actually have to blow this fence up?
Here we go!
What the fuck?
Are you telling me I have to jump over this?
Oh my god!
That's... okay.
No?
It's a fence!
How can we not jump over it?
What the fuck?
How is that fence...
How is that fence so difficult?
Why is jumping forbidden?
This is fucked up.
I caught bullshit.
I caught actual bullshit.
There's no way!
Alright, we gotta find the other entrance.
How the fuck do I get to the other entrance?
Alright.
Apparently this fence is too strong for me.
And I'm lost again.
Okay, here it is.
Oh, it's here.
Can I jump over that?
What kind of answer is that?
There's no way I can jump over that.
Right?
Oh, I can!
Broko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There's no way I can jump over that.
While in jump bot, hold A for a big jump.
Look, I didn't know it looked so high.
I can't believe it.
Yeah, I can't fucking jump over the fence.
Like, what?
First Zeyu's ship, now the Li Sa battleship.
What?
What are they after?
I cannot jump over a fence, but I can jump over that.
Something so valuable, they'd even take on the royal army to get their hands on it.
It's just too high, Doki.
You don't understand.
Hey, is that what we were looking for?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh no.
No, Ching Ling friends, if only we have a large tank like vehicle or demon who is trying to pick up a tank.
They likely headed this way.
Let's take a look.
It's out of respect for any engineer who installed it.
Here we go.
Nice, we got that.
Oh, there's more mats.
Okay.
Grab some- Woo!
That's a nice engine I got.
Ooh!
I love free stuff.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
And we have to go up.
Wait, there's- Oh wait, I thought those were dead people.
This is where we first ran into that guard bot.
Yeah!
I remember.
It's where the prince fell on his- Fell on my what?
What?
Fell on my what?
Finish that sentence!
Fucking coward.
Don't have the balls to say it to my face.
Kiss this way and then to your left.
To the left, to the left!
Speed.
This door is open too!
Oh yeah, this door wasn't open before.
Weird smell.
Weird smell?
What weird smell?
What is it, prince?
It looks like the stairs just keep going up.
Woah!
Oh, and then we're gonna have like a finding hole to place the necklace in.
The fuck?
At least that was sort of fun.
What is he doing here?
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Get out of my 2D platform!
That's fucking right.
We're gonna do...
Nothing!
I feel like I remember that coming up.
Alright.
Nice.
Yeah, what are the loyalists?
I see.
No!
Sorry, I got...
I got a bit distracted.
It's so...
The holes are like very camouflaged.
So like, you zone out for one second and you can't see it.
Woah, who's he?
What the fuck is this guy?
Are you quite sure you checked everywhere?
Bro, your neck is okay?
Yes, sir!
Please, believe me.
General Happy...
Oh my god, it's Tenjin!
Hmm...
If that's the case, then it must be in the engine room.
Happy?
I knew it!
Who?
What's this?
I think I spy some sneaky little rats.
Oh, that's me!
I'm rat!
Bring them before me!
Wait, they have guns though.
Yes, sir!
Are those like night vision goggles?
But it's not even night.
Damn it!
Too late to run now.
Looks like we're in for a rough fight.
Don't worry.
This very fragile bridge can handle the tank.
Boo!
Don't worry!
Surely this tank is not going to fucking blow up!
Surely!
How pathetic of you to lose to the lights of an old demon!
It barely even is!
Hey!
Where did you go?
A perfectly tank-sized catwalk!
Hey!
Where did you go?
Hmm...
It seems that demons lack not only any semblance of intellect, but a sense of humor as well.
Whoa!
What the heck is that supposed to mean?
That's not fair!
Mom says I'm just special.
Whoa!
Okay, this bridge should...
Alright, you know...
I don't think this bridge would fit this.
Guys!
I think my bridge is about to collapse.
Okay!
What material is this bridge made of?
They've brought their tank...
What the fuck on durability is this bridge?
Yeah, just tank the missile.
Oh my god, throw them off the bridge!
If you're evil, you do it, because I do it.
I mean, I'm not evil.
I'm just roleplaying.
Bro,
throw them off the bridge!
Oh my god, bro, these soldiers are so fucking stupid.
Like...
It's literally there.
You can literally throw them off.
At least throw the humans off.
Like they're like, oh but what if it causes bad luck?
Then throw the people!
Like throw the people off!
Yeah, they're superstitious about the demon.
Then what about the regular people?
Just throw them off the bridge!
Let's follow them.
I don't feel comfortable leaving them alone.
They said something about- Oh hey, there's my bra tank!
There's my tank right there.
Never throw people off the bridge if you're not on the fly.
Do you know this half-stache guy?
Yeah, but not that well.
How do you know her?
Or him?
What was that bot of his?
I'm not sure myself.
Thought you'd know.
Alright, let's go up.
We gotta go up.
Go up the ladder.
And we have to go this way.
Whoa!
Okay, don't worry.
I got my tank.
Sweet!
My perfectly placed tank.
Oh shit, no.
We just gotta use this.
What's my HP on my tank?
Okay, good enough.
And then we'll- Oh wait, the little pew-pew-pew gun.
It works just fine.
Easy!
So fucking easy.
Do I need more?
Oh, we have to blow this up.
Okay, and then...
Gotta grab some mats up top.
I see materials up top.
Oh no.
Do I need a jump bot?
Am I too short?
No, wait.
Okay, we needed that anyway.
Is there like an easier- No, I'm too short!
I actually have to get a jump bot!
Okay.
X while jumping in jump bot?
What does that mean?
That's awkward.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
I don't know what to do with this information now.
Wait, what did it look like?
What did it look like, guys, to do that?
Okay.
Gonna destroy this first.
Is there like extra materials down here?
Why did it take me down here?
What?
What's this- Oh there it is!
There it is!
Okay.
There is extra materials.
I was gonna say, I was like, why am I down here?
There it is!
Dude, look at all the extra materials!
All the extra mats!
Woop!
There you go.
Nice.
We got the parallel twin engine.
I assume that's like gonna make me, uh...
Go faster on my bike.
I assume I'm gonna have to do this.
I assume.
Okay, then jump!
Jump!
Oh shit!
Oh thank god!
Thank god there's yellow!
Guys, I love it when there's yellow on boxes so I know where to go.
Okay, nice!
We got the fire ammo!
Alright, how do I get up?
Alright, up I go!
Up I go!
Yay!
Oh, there's more containers!
Nice!
Okay, now get off the bike.
I can't drive on the bridge.
I'm so bad at driving.
I don't really need to use it, but I'll just do it just cause.
Oh, we need to tank again.
And then we need to blow this up.
The bike is too fast, yeah.
It's way too fast for me.
The yellow paint is for game trend list.
Here it is.
I'm glad this game knows me well.
No name!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
That's right, and I'm proud of it.
Guys, if it wasn't for the yellow paint, we would be here forever, guys.
And we don't want that.
Guys, I don't know if you know this, but we don't want to be here forever.
Wait, there's no loot here?
Dude, I assume they would put like an empty box here.
Hi Army IGN.
I'll give you the best reviews ever.
Okay, I feel like tank is better.
The tank definitely causes more damage.
There you go.
And then...
Oh my God, I just hit him and then he fucking fell off.
Bye.
Is that it?
No, there's one more.
My tank literally just poked him once and he just collapsed.
That's actually so sad.
Okay, reloading.
Do I need a loot?
Loot, loot, loot, loot.
No?
Alright, we'll just ride on.
One tap.
Yeah, he got one tapped so badly.
And...
Back here.
Oh shit, that's a bomb!
Okay, nice.
Okay.
We didn't get bombed.
Okay, and then loot.
No, no, get away from me!
Get away from me!
Oh, okay.
Okay, we're gonna have to use a gun.
It's so difficult to shoot that.
Do I need to loot that mist?
No.
Alright, we're good.
Matthew!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Hey.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Oh shit!
No!
Okay.
I didn't miss, guys.
It was planned.
Oh, guys!
Guys, let me see where you are!
Nice.
He's dead.
Yeah!
Leveled up!
We did it!
I assume it's this way.
Aim, don't go...
They're dead?
They're still dead!
So technically I aimed correctly.
Yeah!
That's the crane we saw last time.
Wait, what?
Oh, for, uh, the guard bot we killed last time?
Oh, we have to... we have to shoot that.
Okay.
Where is it?
We gotta shoot this.
There we go.
And then we shoot that.
And then we can get off.
Holy shit.
This is...
I don't know if I can call this a dungeon...
Dungeon.
It's very straightforward.
Not gonna lie.
I wouldn't say this is a dungeon.
This way.
I think it's also because I've done this dungeon before.
Get away!
Nice.
Yeah.
I think it's like I've done this part already before.
So I don't really see this as a dungeon.
Oh my gosh.
It counts!
Wait, yellow paint!
Why does it want me to go here?
Oh my god, there's yellow paint.
There's yellow paint.
That means there should be loot.
I'm gonna go to the other side.
I know there's a quest over there, but the yellow paint, guys!
We can't just ignore the yellow paint!
We gotta follow the paint, guys!
Oh shit, wrong one.
Wait, the yellow paint stopped.
Oh no.
Oh wait, there's loot!
Guys, what do you do when the yellow paint stops?
Guys...
Oh no.
I'm so lost without my yellow paint!
It's the worst thing that could happen to me!
When there's no more yellow paint!
What do I do?
Do I go...
this way?
Is there extra loot?
Am I going the right way?
I can't tell!
Oh, I'm gonna go this way.
I'm gonna get lost.
It has to be this way, because there's so many enemies out of nowhere.
Yeah, it has to be this way.
So that means there has to be like a boss here or something.
Follow...
Oh, the yellow light!
You're right!
We gotta follow the yellow light!
Alright.
Oh, there's loot!
There's loot!
Wait, that's it?
I did all of that for this one box?
There's no way!
There has to be more!
There has to be...
Oh, it's the rusty thing!
Wait, it's rusty!
I knew it!
Guys, I don't know how to get back, but guys, think about the loot though!
Okay.
Let's see...
Oh my god, look at all this loot!
This is everything we worked for!
And we got a heat upgraded gun?!
Nice.
Alright.
We did it.
We worked so hard for this.
Wheeee!
Alright, off we go.
Okay, back to the main quest line now.
The loot goblin mode.
Guys, we need to upgrade our tanks!
Now back to the main quest.
If I can remember how to get there.
Okay, we gotta keep jumping.
There's someone down there.
Yeah, that's my team!
Because they're not allowed to ride in the same car as me.
So I make them walk.
Oh, this way.
Oh, there's the yellow lights.
Marsha, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I can't call this a dungeon.
It's too straightforward.
It gets lost in me easily.
That's different, guys!
That's different!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Wait, is it this way?
Oh, shit, guys.
I don't know.
Guys, where did I come from?
Oh, here, here, here!
This was the yellow paint!
This is where it all started!
Where it all started, the yellow paint.
Oh, nice.
Yeah!
Wait, engine rooms above us?
I thought engine rooms in the basement.
This way.
It's really like an area that we should...
Oh, it's this way.
Hello, guys!
Are you guys gonna watch?
Okay.
Yay, we got desert crocodile!
Whoa!
What are you doing here?
You're not authorized to be here!
Get out!
Nobody likes you!
That's right.
Nobody loves you.
You're just a pure...
You're just an imitation of the real thing.
Alright.
Nice getting rid of that.
Do I need extra loot?
I'm always here for extra loot, guys.
Okay.
Jump.
No!
My head!
I like that.
Yeah, what's his name?
What's his name?
If you like that guy so much, what was he called?
Ooh.
This seems like a... Yeah, that seems like a tank fight.
Alright.
I like... I should just kill these guys with a tank.
It's just much faster.
It's just so much faster.
Oh, shit!
Get away!
Is that it?
That's all of them, right?
Just like that guy?
You like that guy?
Name every guy.
Exactly!
I'm glad you understand.
Okay, we gotta get rid of the small... these guys.
Wait, what?
What blocked it?
Okay, where's the other one?
There he is.
Oh, shi... Come on!
Why are my missiles so tiny?
There we go.
Should be everything.
Steve!
That's my good friend Steve.
Steve Robotman.
Alright.
We gotta get rid of this.
And then this.
Alright.
Yay!
Steve no...
Steve with the leg.
My good buddy Steve.
Steve Lego.
Oh, there's more loot.
Got another engine.
Oh my god.
So much loot.
And...
Whoa!
So many robots for me.
Why are you hiding in the corner?
Bro, join the army!
Join the fun!
What are you afraid of?
Oh, shit.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna stand still.
Just stand still and do all the work.
We don't have to dodge anything.
Oh, wait.
Is that...
Okay.
There has to be loot on this other side.
Right?
I don't think so, guys.
No.
I don't want to waste my time.
Wait!
Yellow!
The yellow light!
There has to be loot over here!
Oh my god!
I fucking knew it!
Here we go!
The yellow light!
Always follow the yellow!
Is there anything here?
Oh my god!
I knew it!
I knew there was always loot here.
Thank you.
Thank god for yellow!
Okay.
Faith in the yellow.
Okay, and you go back.
Boop!
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, and I'll just ride the bike.
Because it's faster.
No!
It's so hard to ride bikes inside.
Professor Oak was right.
No!
Professor Oak was right!
You should never ride the bike inside!
As if!
Come on!
Let's check out that engine room!
Are we there yet?
Are we near the engine room now?
Oh, we have to be.
There's a...
The water here.
There you go.
I should be able to drink in the tank so my tank automatically gets healed from water.
I'll swap in your equipment now.
Oh, the customization?
Alright.
What is this?
What the fuck?
Is it better?
I can't tell.
Keep upgraded.
Uh... Require...
Let's see.
Weapon...
It can break?!
Shots exploded.
Your vehicle is too low leveled?!
Oh my god.
What?
You mean my vehicle is too low leveled?
What do you mean?
I can't believe it.
How dare they say that?
You're not low level!
Okay.
V8 engine.
Boost gauge use.
Plus 37.
Boost recovery.
Boost accelerator.
Built for speed.
Oh, I like speed though.
Maybe we should get speed.
Wait.
I don't know.
Do we get this?
V8 should be better.
Okay.
Reinforced fender.
At the cost of speed.
Well, I just had speed fixed but then I have better defense.
So I might as well.
I'm at fires and incoming adds armor place for enhance.
I feel like defense is better.
Yeah, I'm gonna get the defense.
Power plus chip.
Uh...
Oh.
Wait.
No!
Dragoons!
This is why I have better Dragoons!
Oh my god.
Better Dragoons.
How could you betray me like that?
After I like...
After I fucking shut you out.
A scam.
Oh my god.
All my vehicles are too low level.
You're all babies!
Wait.
What is he holding?
Is that the power?
How can we compete with that?
Is that what he was after?
That's the...
That has to be like a power core.
Oh no.
You've got to be kidding me.
What is it?
Yeah.
That's...
Okay.
Equanium.
Equanium?
Equa...
Sorry.
It just sounds like baby talk.
Put it on the ground carefully.
Oh my god.
Is that a queen?
I just bump could trigger a massive explosion.
Oh really?
The uranium of this world.
It's just...
Talk for uranium.
You mean like this?
What?
We just said it'll fucking cause an explosion.
No.
Everyone.
Get down!
What?
Oh my god.
It's a queen.
Wait.
Nothing happened.
That was anticlimactic.
Uh huh.
Yeah.
Didn't explode?
Don't you st...
You fools.
Oh he's crazy.
He just threw that.
It's been out of the equanium furnace.
I'm sorry.
It's been out of the equanium.
Oh it only explodes at high temperatures.
You think that's funny?
You jerk!
Hand over the equanium.
It's not something humanity can be trusted with.
I can't hear it.
Why didn't you guys...
You guys.
I can't.
I can't hear it every time.
Oh.
Of course.
As is.
Do you take me for a fool?
Don't worry old man.
I'll get it back by force.
Oh shit.
Alright.
It's okay.
I have the missile.
Go ahead and try.
I'll humor you.
Your fault.
You did this.
Absolutely cannot hand over the equanium.
No!
I ruined it!
Every time he saves it now it's just in my mind.
Guys I ruined it.
What the fuck happened to my t- Okay there he is.
Can I just shoot him from up here?
Yeah.
Doki how could you do this?
Oh shit!
What the fuck!
Okay we're gonna...
Let me get that... remember that missile thing?
Let me fucking...
I can't swapp- Okay.
Guys I didn't realize.
Oh no.
We gotta get rid of the little guys though.
Oh we gotta get rid of the little guys.
Oh.
Oh that...
If only I had that...
He jumped over it?
Okay that's not fair.
He literally jumped over it.
What the f- you can do that?
He's an ass.
But a dangerous one Prince.
Wait wait wait what was the one?
Guys what was the move?
That lets you...
Let me see you summon people.
I forgot.
Guys you guys remember?
How do I summon people?
Really capstache?
I don't remember!
Okay.
Get rid of these guys.
There was- you can summon people!
How do I use the ally skills?
I don't remember!
Oh god.
Okay nice we got rid of him.
On the controller!
Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa.
Oh god.
I don't remember how to summon allies!
LB!
Oh LB.
LB LB!
RAL go in there!
Shoot your guy- oh shit yes go Ral go!
Oh my god Ral's actually helpful!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
No no no Ral I'm not letting you take this kill!
That robot's so much- Yeah but he's dead!
That robot's dead!
Someone help!
Save me from this frightful fiend!
I did it guys!
What the fuck?
Hey come to Spino!
We're looking for new villi- like citizens!
They're on a lunch break.
We're always looking for new citizens at Spino!
Whoa!
Aq-WOW!
Not the Aquamium!
Oh whoa not the Aquamium!
Why is it that everyone we fight is so good at running away?
I'll inform Ari.
We'll let the army pursue Epi.
Stop!
The Aquanium is our top priority now.
There might still be some left in the engine room.
Let's go check.
I think my favorite is hearing an old man call us the Aquamium.
God damn it Doki you ruined it!
That word is ruined for him!
I like when Rouse says it too.
I feel like it's even worse when Rouse says it though.
I love how we got back from Epi.
Must've been the only one.
Does every battleship have one?
Garry thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
That's why they went for Zeyu's ship!
What do you mean?
Zeyu's personal battleship isn't as big as the Lisav battleship, but it's still huge.
Antigrav stones alone wouldn't be enough to fly it.
But Aquamium.
That could probably do the trick.
Ah that's why I didn't need it!
No!
How much does it say this way?
I can't hear it, Doki!
Why did you do this to us?!
I heard you mention it on the radio, but...
I like how it's just rousing it too.
It was a gigantic explosion which destroyed a vast area.
And the cause, or rather the fuel used to generate it, was Aquanium.
It's the simple things that make me laugh.
The great Aquanium explosion!
I'm sorry to pry, but it feels like there's more to this story.
You don't trust me enough to tell me?
What's the real story, Rao?
Get out of my head!
There's something I haven't been able to bring myself to tell you either.
Dear god, what's this?
Oh, no, this is your Aquarium!
I'm sorry, but I'm not sure what you're talking about.
Thank you for the super chat, dear god.
Thank you, thank you.
My show's... oh, what's this?
Did you drop the Aquarium and make a Blu-ray that killed 10,000 people?
Wow!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I feel you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Aquarium's gonna be stuck in my head for a week.
You're right.
Let's get back.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Alright, nice.
Is this... is the arc over?
Are we done with...
Are we done with the... the O-O-Fi's uranium?
This is a serious situation, Doki, out there.
Then don't name it Aquarium!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
They literally couldn't have named it anything else.
That epi guy.
He ran off down this side passage, didn't he?
Could very well be a shortcut.
Let's find out.
Alright.
It's a shortcut?
I like shortcuts.
I love shortcuts.
Okay, this is not as short as I thought it was.
Thief.
Liar.
You said this was a shortcut.
A shortcut should be like fast travel.
The Great O-O-R.
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh, I passed Materials?
Oh, whatever.
It's fine.
That's fine.
I mean, I could go back up and get it.
Alright.
Let's go back up.
I mean, I could... I'll just bring out my bike.
What if I can just like walk off?
No, I can't.
Oh, I can't walk off.
Even though it feels like there's stuff here.
This is the longest... I missed Materials?
Where?
Did I get gaslighted?
I got gaslighted?
Where the fuck are these Materials that gaslight?
Oh, there it is.
No, I didn't.
Oh my god.
My Dragoon's not lying to me?
What is this?
Ha ha ha ha!
Holy shit, guys.
He didn't lie.
He didn't lie at all.
What a legend.
Okay.
Nice.
What the heck?
Okay.
I need to... Get me out of that bike!
Get me off this bike so I can get down!
Not so Deadpool!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Remember Doki, even in Apex you'll be shooting at a cranium.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
My my, thank you for the super chat!
One out of ten, don't lie to Thor!
Ha ha ha ha!
It's true.
Alright.
Nice.
And then we leave.
Wait, a new general.
Who's this guy?
Elvis?
Pompous Man?
Elvis in my anime game?
The King.
Ha ha ha!
Why do I have two exclamation points?
Are they like quests here?
Oh, they just have new stuff.
A car blueprint?
I don't need another car.
Alright, let's head home.
Back to Spino we go.
The King, he's back!
We ran into that armed group at the Lee Saab battleship.
What?
So that smoke must have been their doing.
It's fine though.
We thumped them good.
Yeah, we th- beat them.
My apologies that you had to deal with them.
We had our hands full subduing the detachment of enemies who went north.
Wait, who were the people who went north then?
The Royal Army and Chaos.
We barely managed to fend them off.
They'll likely rejoin and cause more unrest.
They're with Zeu.
But who are they?
No idea.
All we know is that they're both well organized.
And well armed.
They're the Forestland Army.
The Forestland?
It's Greenland!
But... that's impossible.
We signed an armistice with Forestland decades ago.
I like we have Sandland and then Forestland.
Like I...
But like the thing is, this land isn't even called Sandland officially.
I'm pretty sure.
Where we're at, it's not even officially called Sandland.
But yet, we have Forestland.
So...
But...
Is it actually officially called Sandland?
But like...
Sandland was like...
artificially made because of one dickhead that decided to build a dam.
Like...
That's the thing.
Forest... like...
Sandland was artificially made.
And it was so fucked up too.
If you think about it.
I also find it hard to believe.
But...
They call their commander General.
That only adds up if they're part of a large official military.
Yes, but...
What makes you so certain that it's the Forestland Army?
Well...
Is there going to be Waterland?
Don't feel you have to share it here if it isn't a waterland.
It involves your family.
Sandland is AI generated.
I think he should know too though.
No, Greenland...
We all know Greenland is a real country.
Forestland is basically bootleg Greenland.
But like...
Greenland is actually like Iceland.
And Iceland is Greenland.
Because Greenland is actually incredibly cold.
But Iceland is the actual non- Iceland is the actual not cold area.
General Ahri.
Would you mind coming alone?
Understood.
Please, lead the way.
Alright.
Follow me.
So you get click baited.
Greenland and Iceland click baits you.
Alright, we got it.
Oh, the cat!
Njaginbu wants to talk to us.
Alright.
Hey!
Nice to see you again!
Is it just my imagination?
Or has the town gotten more lively?
Yeah, I did that!
I found something cool!
Oh, thank you!
Yeah, I can't afford anything.
Because I have not been exploring.
That's okay.
Wait, why are you so short?
Oh my god!
Sorry!
Dookie, you're not supposed to just ask somebody why they're so short!
Sorry.
I just wasn't expecting that.
He's wide!
Let's hear it.
The reason I can be so sure they're from Forestland...
Are you from Forestland?
Is because I'm also originally from Forestland.
You are a Forestland person?
What did you say?
You are...
You're an illegal immigrant?
Oh my god!
She's an illegal immigrant!
Guys, I can say it because it's...
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
She's an illegal immigrant!
You can't!
Basically, it means she's not allowed in this country.
Deporter!
Wow!
That's bad!
Why did you decide to come here on your own?
We translated it!
We have aliens in the workshop!
But I was the only one who made it.
Oh my god!
There are several illegal immigrants!
What compels you to take the risk of coming to Sandland?
I wanted to find people willing I wanted to find people willing to help us overthrow the Forestland government.
Oh my god.
She doesn't have a video.
Lisa, guys.
She's taking hard working Sattelander's jobs.
That's so dead-full.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh no!
She actually took our jobs!
Sattelander's the land of opportunity!
An imprisoned kind King Jam out of nowhere!
Is he wearing a helmet with a horn on top?
The forest land army!
Oh no, that's the supreme general.
Magic, thank you for the super chat.
Bro, what the fuck?
The helmet is like not doing it justice.
We've crossed blades with that general Epi you fought on the Lisa battleship before.
What do you think?
General RA.
Breadth the leader.
I'll admit, it does line up with our intel on forest land.
It's perfect for us.
Don't worry, you get the pass, green card.
I think so too.
The timing of all this makes total sense.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The sand land dream.
The way the chaos downfall would be the perfect time for a rival nation to move against us.
But surely, they must realize the severe consequences of such aggression.
What could possibly motivate them to take the risk of invading us?
Aquanium.
Thanks, Fou.
What?
Impossible.
Our entire supply was lost in that explosion thirty years ago.
That's not so the Lissa battleship was powered by Aquaenium and I'd bet good money that say use mobile fortress was as well.
Stop!
NO, STOP.
We can't take out the battle ship's aquanium.
Dark God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We have demons and we have aliens.
Not exactly the aliens you would expect though.
Yeah, what about the Aquanium?
Someone else please say it.
Stop making Rao say it.
I don't know.
You're an illegal immigrant.
Oh no.
I can't believe this is this game.
What the fuck?
Bro.
Bro, I can't believe they called her an illegal immigrant.
What the fuck?
That's like the most out of pocket shit.
Oh my real life.
Oh my God.
That's a real written line in this game.
You know what?
I'm glad I did a part three.
It was so worth it.
It seems to refer to those fighting against Commander Bread and his army who stole control over forest land from its king in a military coup.
Oh.
So basically all it is is a bunch of people who really hate them?
Yeah.
Well, it's a military... Wait, but it's like a military coup.
That's like the worst one.
Isn't it?
Like that's the one you don't want to happen.
Gamble, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Razadoki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dude, that's real bad.
I've been thinking rather than just talking.
I'm glad we went with the English.
The English.
It's something I should show you.
Will you come with me?
Sure.
But where?
The site of the great Aquanium explosion.
Oh.
All right.
I'll come.
I like how serious he just got.
He's like, oh shit, the Aquanium?
All right, I'll come.
Stop saying it, Raph.
I got to follow.
You know what?
I'm going to call it here, guys.
I think this is the perfect time to call it today.
Everything... all the stuff we went through.
I think this is the perfect time to call this part of the stream.
Rallbacks.
Don't worry, part four.
We'll do Rall's backstory in part four.
Guys, I had a great time.
I've been enjoying...
I've been enjoying this game a lot so far.
Let me swap real quick.
Yeah.
Honestly, this game has been incredibly enjoyable.
I've been like... I really like the story.
I think like the only issue I had was that dungeon.
The last dungeon.
Only because like if it was a new area, I would be fine.
But the fact that like we had to redo...
Like not redo the dungeon.
But like...
You know like...
It's like a different...
A bit different but it was still the same.
So like that was my only issue with the...
With the dungeon.
If it was a new dungeon, I would have been fine.
But I didn't like that I had to like redo it.
Yeah.
But...
I've been having a really...
I wish they didn't have to reuse it for the new plot area.
Anyway.
Let's read some super chats everybody.
Okay.
We're gonna change the...
Uh...
We didn't get...
We didn't get to Greenland.
Wait, wait.
Okay, wait, wait.
New title.
Off to...
We got chairs...
Wait.
Off to...
No, no, no.
We didn't get to Greenland.
Yeah.
We should just do that.
I don't want...
I want the VOD watchers to feel the growth of the chairs.
We didn't get to Greenland.
Um...
NS, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This turn of events is hurting my aquarium.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Magic, thank you for the super chat.
Don't tell Aisah I was here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Like the worst part, I think when they were like, oh my God, she's an illegal immigrant, was when the...
Oh, no spoilers?
Okay.
Off.
We'll just write...
Off to Greenland.
Okay.
We'll just put...
We don't want to spoil it.
We don't...
Was when the general was like super surprised.
That was like the reaction to it was the most fucked up part.
The fact that it's like, you're a criminal.
It's actually fucking crazy.
I was just like shocked.
It like...
I was like...
Actually, I was so shocked because like, I didn't expect that to be written out and also dumb.
And the fact that it was like, there were several of us, but only I made it.
I'm like, oh my God.
What the fuck?
It just came out of nowhere.
It actually was just...
It just happened.
I'm like, oh my God.
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Next stream time, two-week sad land.
No!
No, Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It got really real.
Like it really.
I got real there.
Yeah, we overthrew a government and then suddenly illegal immigrants.
I'm like, what?!
Guess, it's been a real comfy.
I loving the sad land playthrough.
Thank you for super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I've been really... I've definitely been really enjoying this.
I feel like, you know, especially when a lot of us are going in blind, like we don't know what's gonna happen and everything.
And then like, we've been surprised.
There's so many moments where we're just very surprised.
So, I've been having a... I've been having a great time just like enjoying the... I guess like reacting to it blind.
Because it's honestly been a fucking adventure.
It's been such a fucking adventure.
Alright, let's get some... which one?
Which one have we not read?
Oh my gosh, I read a lot that's coming in.
So, I don't know which one I haven't read yet.
I've been thinking about Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You create an army of people willing to go to war with each other over ice cream flavors.
Doki, you made us this way.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Random, thank you for the Super Chat.
Doki, a whaling fund.
Let's go!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not so Deadpool, thank you for the Super Chat.
Um...
Link...
Yeah, I read a lot while coming in.
So, I like don't know which one I haven't...
I'm trying to remember which one I haven't read yet.
Uh...
Sharko, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
A bit of people here who don't even know about the Burger King rap commercial about SpongeBob Square Ass.
Wait, is that real?
Wait, I'm one of them.
What the fuck?
How old are you, Sharko?
I'm joking.
Wait, this is 15 years ago.
What the heck?
What is this?
This is the thing that Sharko wanted us to watch.
What the fuck?
Wait, Sharko, don't tell us your age.
We don't want you to talk straight age.
What the fuck?
Like, what is this?
Oh my god!
When is that?
When is 15 years ago?
There's a million views on this?
2009!
I'm surprised I actually didn't know about this.
2009.
Don't worry.
You didn't read this one yet.
I got your back, Doki.
A fire!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm surprised I actually didn't know about this.
Doki's got brain rot.
Johnny Lacombe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, not super chat.
Membership.
Thank you for the gifted membership.
Thank you.
Uh...
It's like I know a lot of, like, internet shit.
So I'm really surprised I actually don't know about the fucking Burger King SpongeBob.
I think they phased out the Burger King, man.
Because they realized that, like, he's a little... freaky.
Because I don't see him anymore.
They phased out a lot of, like, the fast food mascots because we don't see Ronald McDonald anymore.
We don't see... Okay, to be fair, the reason why we don't see Ronald McDonald anymore is because at one point in history, we had a killer clown phase.
Where, like, people were randomly dressed up as clowns at night to just freak people out.
So then the McDon... the Ronald McDonald's company was like, We are gonna make sure...
The McDonald's company slowly phased out Ronald McDonald because of the whole, like, clowns dressed up...
Like... like creepy clowns dressed up at night.
Yeah!
And then at one point, it got really bad because serial killers were starting to dress up like the clowns.
Because they think they could get away with it.
So there was an actual serial killer that dressed up as the clowns.
At night.
Because they were like, Oh, other people are dressing up as clowns at night.
So they'll just think I'm a prankster.
So then... so then people were... stopped doing it.
Because they're like, Oh my God!
Maybe we should stop.
Because actual serial killers were using it.
So then... then it just... the whole clowns at night thing just suddenly stopped happening.
That was fun actually...
No, it was not fun!
Because actual murderers started getting involved guys!
Actual murderers started getting involved.
So then it stopped.
Yeah.
And like... and then I remember there was like that other... the Jack guy.
Was it Jack in the Box?
Oh, I love the Jack in the Box guy though.
I miss... I miss the Jack in the Box commercials.
Because I actually thought he was like...
The commercials with that guy.
Who is he?
Okay...
Um... he was a guy that wore this giant white head with a cone hat.
Um... I don't see Jack in the Box guy anymore.
To be fair.
Jack in the Box guy is kinda hot.
It's just because he wears a suit doesn't mean he's hot.
Guys, I swear...
I swear anytime some random guy wears a suit, people will be like, but he's hot.
But then you... like he doesn't even show the face.
It's like they'll just put a helmet... like...
It's like they just put a helmet on him.
And then you guys will be like, oh my god, he's so hot.
Just because he has a suit on.
The mask stays on.
Okay, but here we...
It's always a damn suit.
Only if the suit is well tailored.
You don't want somebody to wear a suit...
Um... that's like oversized.
Or like too...
Okay, to be fair.
Some people will be like, no Doki.
If it's too tight, it's even better.
Doki.
But if you see a guy wearing a suit that's too big for him.
Or a girl that's wearing a suit too big for him.
For them.
It's not... not hot.
Um...
The Slenderman effect.
That's true.
People actually thought Slenderman was hot.
I mean, there was a whole shit about like...
Those kids that murdered because they were trying to murder for Slenderman.
That was so fucked up.
I remember people...
Yeah, some...
Yeah, it's the...
There was...
I don't know if people forgot about it.
There was like two little girls.
Two little girls like murdered their...
Like tried to murder their friend.
Real by the way.
This is a real story.
Two little girls tried to murder their friend.
For Slenderman.
Because they were like, we have to do it for Slenderman.
To summon him.
And shit like that.
And then that's why Slenderman isn't talked about anymore.
It's like...
It's like when murder gets involved, people just stop talking about it.
Because they're like, this is a...
This is pretty bad.
No, it wasn't a...
It actually happened.
She survived.
Yeah, it was attempted murder.
They were like 12 years old.
Yeah, yeah.
And then like...
Because Slenderman was like really popular.
It was like super popular.
And then that happened.
And then nobody really talks about Slenderman anymore.
Nobody talks.
Because they're like, whoa.
Maybe we should stop.
Oh my god.
Yeah, it was fucking crazy.
That was a crazy time.
And that's why Slenderman just suddenly stopped happening.
Like people just stopped talking about Slenderman.
Because people were like, holy fuck.
Wait.
There's real murders happening now.
Like the clown shit.
That's why people stopped fucking dressing up as clowns at night time.
Because murderers were like, I'm gonna start dressing up as a clown too.
Because nobody can catch me if everybody else is dressed up as a clown.
Sleepy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Usni, I refuse to accept the slander.
They sell a thirst trap calendar on the official...
Wait, what?
Jack in the box calendar.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god.
Wait, he was not joking.
2024.
Wait, I'm gonna put this on my screen.
Oh my...
Guys, it's like the fireman shit.
But for like fast food.
Okay, I'm gonna put this on my screen.
You guys need to see this.
This is actually crazy.
What the fuck?
This is actually...
Wait, this is actually real.
Look at this.
Jack's thirst trap.
You weren't familiar with this game.
Wait, he has a ring on.
Is that a wedding ring, Jack?
How dare you?
Wait, is Jack in the box?
Is that the wedding?
Is that the wedding hat?
I don't know.
Jack in the box.
Jack's married.
He's married?
Cricket?
Who is she?
Jack...
Jack's wife.
Cricket.
Jack in the box.
How dare he be married?
No way.
I can't.
Oh my God.
His wife doesn't even have the head.
What the fuck?
The wife is just a regular person.
So that we can all be like the wife.
Wait, what the fuck?
The wife is just a regular person.
Oh my God.
I can't believe it.
He has kids too.
How could Jack do this to us?
Did you ask him?
I thought it'd be like another person with the head.
Oh my God.
There was a petition to nominate him for people's sexiest man alive.
Wait, what?
Make Jackbox people's sexiest man alive.
What is this?
Wait, this is from the official TikTok.
Oh my God.
Bro.
What?
When?
Guys, look at this.
Wait, this is real.
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
We're looking at Jack from Jack and the Bugs.
Look at this one.
I think I'm...
Holy shit.
Okay.
Is someone's gonna break the mode of what society thinks is sexy?
Or...
Why not Jack?
Let's make Jackbox the official sexiest man alive.
Oh my God.
I don't know if...
I did not intend to go down the Jack in the Box rabbit hole, guys.
I...
Well, hello there.
Damn.
Jack is fucking ripped.
He is looking good.
Bro, is anybody ordering Jack in the Box tonight, guys?
Who is ordering some Jack in the Box, guys?
Okay.
Let me check out...
Oh my God.
Bro, he has a Funko Pop too?
Jack in the Box has a Funko Pop and I don't.
Okay, I need to know what other pictures are on this.
Looking...
Oh my God.
What the fuck am I...
Okay, guys.
You guys gotta see the calendar.
Here's like some of the preview pictures that I saw here.
I'm gonna save this.
Oh my God.
I need to save this for you guys.
Okay.
Look at this.
Okay, whoever took photos of this, they know what they're...
They know the target audience.
Why?
Why is he so damn ripped?
Damn.
This has to be for like October.
I don't know.
I forgot.
What's American Thanksgiving?
Whatever American Thanksgiving is.
I don't know.
That is...
There you go.
There's Jack.
Oh my.
Look at those curly fries.
All right.
I think that's a good time to call it here, guys.
I had a great time talking to you guys and also playing Sand Land today.
I can't believe we spent majority of that customizing our town, but at least we finished one of the dungeons for the...
One out of the three dungeons for Greenland.
Hey, guys.
Guys, tomorrow we have Minecraft Twitch Rivals on Sunday.
But next week is also more chill.
We do have like, I think like one collab.
I moved around my collabs.
Because we originally have collabs next week.
But then like, I want to relax and chill after WrestleTuber.
But I haven't had a chance to really relax.
Because it has been like back to back to back events lately.
So, it's gonna be like Sajam Slam.
Then WrestleTuber.
And then like a lot of collabs and stuff in between.
So like, we're taking next week really chill.
But tomorrow will be a Minecraft Twitch Rivals.
And if I... it really depends on like how far I make it in the Twitch Rivals.
Because it's like... it's supposed to be like a 5-6 day event.
Only if you don't get eliminated.
So like each day they start... they eliminate people.
So there's a lot of people participating.
I think like more than 100 content creators are participating.
I'll put a waiting room up so you guys can see.
Oh wait, no.
JK, it's on Twitch.
I'll give you guys the time on Twitter.
So follow me on Twitter so you guys know what time it is for the Twitch Rivals.
Because I'll be streaming on Twitch.
Anyway guys, as always everybody stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!